Yeah,
he's a,
I think he's too smart,
too smart to talk to regular people.
Boom.
Powerful big wave surfer.
How are you buddy?
I'm great.
We just got back from playing little
techno hunt.
We did manage a greatest thing of all
time,
right?
I was just saying I don't care what the
price is.
It's worth it.
It's a bargain at twice the price of
whatever it is.
Yeah.
Where people don't know what it is.
It's his game that it simulates
bowhunting.
So what it is,
is,
is a giant screen that's made out of
Kevlar and then uh,
it's got us like a projector projects,
hd images of elk and deer.
You could set it up for a bunch of
different animals,
but elk and deer walk across the screen
and you shoot at them and it's like the
perfect.
There's a,
we show a little video,
Shane bannon earlier.
It's really cool,
man.
It's a perfect practice for bow hunting
because one of the things about bow
hunting is you get nervous and the more
you could do something like this,
we just shot a perfect shot.
The more you could do that.
Over and over and over again,
the more it becomes ingrained in your,
your,
your nervous system,
ingrained in your muscles,
ingrained in your memory,
and then it becomes natural.
Yeah,
it's awesome.
it's pretty dope.
We're going to make this podcast about
15 minutes long.
Go back and shit.
Yeah,
that's what we were actually talking
about.
Cutting off the podcast.
Short for that.
So tell me about this movie man.
Yeah.
So I'm in La for the premier,
the HBO Premiere of the Momentum
Generation.
It's a,
it's a,
uh,
it's a sports documentary that,
that,
uh,
that Hbo and Robert Redford did.
So it's cool,
man.
It's,
it's,
it's really cool.
It's um,
it's a story about my friends and I,
we,
you know,
we all grew up a competitive surfers and
in high school we all sort of met each
other through,
through competitions competing.
So this tells a story of how he,
basically,
how we met,
how we grew up,
um,
and how we became friends and family
basically like traveling around the
world,
you know,
together as basically like little kids
with no with no chaperones on,
on tour around the world.
So it's fucking crazy.
It's,
it's a,
it's a wild story.
Pulled us up to keep this like a fist
away.
How old were you when you first started
surfing?
Started surfing on a standup surfboard
when I was five.
And when did you start traveling?
Serve?
When I was 12,
I went to England for the world amateur
championships.
So I was on the Hawaii Team doing this
traveling surfing thing most of your
life?
Yeah.
Wow,
that's crazy.
That is nuts,
man.
I been,
I been putting my surfboards in a board
bag and walking out the door with my
passport since I was 12 and going to so
many different destinations around the
world,
literally just for surfing wire nuts
does such a crazy way to grow up and
that.
That's a cool thing about the film is
all of us have that in common and it's
crazy the way the story set up too
because there's so many things in it
that I didn't really realize were
happening at the time.
Like,
like I came from,
I came from a broken family,
alcoholic father,
kind of radical situation at home and
then like a lot of us had like broken
families,
a lot of us had that in common so we
sort of have like this weird fucked up
family dynamic in common.
So we all became sort of like our own
family on the road.
So we were competing for a world title.
We're all competing and going around the
world all the time,
staying together.
So we became best friends like this
nucleus of surfers and we all just
became ultra close and then when things
get really serious with a surfing
competition and there was a lot on the
line with sponsors and money and big
brands coming in.
The shit hit the fan.
And then we started like breaking up.
It got two series.
It was almost like a band who just
couldn't stand each other anymore or
things got too radical,
you know,
girls got in the way or money got in the
way.
And so there was like this kinda like
breaking up element,
you know,
throughout our group.
Wow.
I would imagine when you're living like
that,
those people must be so valuable for you
though.
People that can understand your way of
life because it's their way of life too,
because like to to a regular person who
commutes every day and goes to an office
comes home like your life is alien.
Yeah,
it is.
I still get like,
I still get uncomfortable when people
asked me what I do for a living,
you know,
like I'll be in like a normal random
setting and some of you,
the Leo,
what do you do for a living?
And I'm like,
no,
do not ask me that because nobody
understands.
You know?
It's like,
what do you tell them?
I tell them the truth,
but it's,
I just always tell them like it's,
it's really hard to explain.
But I served for a living and do,
what the fuck is that?
Yeah.
Did they go?
How does that work?
How do you get paid?
Yes.
All the time.
And I just go.
I have no idea.
Well,
you don't really compete any longer
right now.
Just not at all ride big waves.
I do.
All right.
Big Waves,
that's my focus and I also write all
kinds of waves.
I surf every day and you know,
the waves don't get big that often when
the waves are biggest,
I'm on it.
Yeah.
For a person that like is just meeting
you for the first time and doesn't
understand surfing and is trying to wrap
their head around making a living,
riding the waves of the ocean.
It was a house wife.
Wait a minute.
No,
I went to accounting school and I and I
don't have,
there's not like a,
there's nothing.
I mean there's,
there's not like another category I can
really point to,
to,
to make the point go quicker to.
There's not like,
um,
you know,
it's like there's basketball players and
football players and all of them were
like scoring goals and getting these
brand endorsements from that,
from competition element.
So because I'm a free surfer who doesn't
compete at all,
it's just,
it's hard to wrap your head around,
but they've been harder.
Yeah.
Basically,
I,
you know,
uh,
I have a,
a large surfing profile and so like I
work with a lot of brands and that's
just the kind of,
the way it works.
It just sponsors.
Yep.
Yeah.
Now this movie,
this documentary,
did they have footage of you guys from
when you were really young?
Oh yeah,
yeah,
they do.
Is that weird watching that stuff?
Yeah,
very weird because we're all in our
forties now.
We all got kids and for most of us,
except for Kelly Kelly still going,
you 40,
46 years old.
I,
I saw him on your show the other day is
pretty classic,
but so,
so he's like a focal point in the film.
He's,
he's part of the momentum generation and
um,
and so he,
there is incredible footage of him when
he's nine years old or 10 years old and
he's in Florida,
like a little rat,
like a little sunburn rat and it's neat.
You know what I mean?
I mean we all had that in common.
That's we,
we all grew up in,
in different places and then we all fell
in love with surfing,
you know,
separately,
and then we all just became super tight,
so.
Wow.
It was great.
It's a,
it's great.
And then now we're all like best friends
again because there's no,
there's no points on a line or a world
title on the line or like brands getting
in the way or girls getting in the way.
We're all,
we're all,
you know,
we're finally growing up that.
I mean that had to be strange though to
be so tight and then everything sort of
get bottlenecked by the pressure.
Yup.
Anything serving,
how much pressure could there be?
But you know,
we're all trying to make a living,
right?
It's like,
no,
you know,
that was our dream to surf as much as
possible and see the world and that's
the only way you could do it for us.
Whenever there's competition,
there's got to be massive amounts of
pressure.
Whenever there's someone trying to
achieve something or someone trying to
rise to the top of a profession and
you're surrounded by a bunch,
but you also must have pushed each other
to and it must have been beneficial to
have people like you around as well.
I think it's part of,
it's just,
you know,
I think it's like part of our,
our human DNA to,
you know,
to be naturally competitive.
So I think especially men,
I think that we feel like we have
something to prove,
you know,
like where we stand compared to the
other guys were,
whether it was like in the cave man days
or,
or like the,
you know,
the first hunters.
Whereas it was like for sure they were
there.
They were competitive too so you could
bring home meat for the,
for the tribe.
And then it just kept going from there.
And,
and,
and now we,
we,
we compete with whatever we're into and
you know,
for us with surfing we came hyper
competitive and especially me like from
the time I was like maybe 16 or 17 total
time,
I was like my mid twenties.
I was like super competitive where I
want to rip people's heads off my heat,
like I would like visualize horrible,
horrible things happening to them while
I was competing against them and it's so
crazy how that's gone.
One hundred percent gone from my.
My being now,
I can't even imagine doing that.
I'm like the most relaxed,
non competitive person.
I have no competitiveness left in my
body.
Well,
I've only known you for what,
four years or something like that in
those years I could not imagine you have
an evil thoughts towards someone who
seem so chill.
I was a shit talker.
Or are you really?
Yeah,
I,
I remember I was surfing as this Guy
Damien hardman and,
and he was like an Australian world
champion.
He was like an older generation.
We were from the young new school
generation were coming up and there's
these established guys who didn't want
it,
but you know,
like bd thrown in.
There was this Guy Damien hardman who is
a bad ass competitive surfer,
but he was a very like tactician
conservative.
You'd never fall.
He seemed like a nerd in me.
You know what I mean?
I was like raw kid from Hawaii and this
guy was like so presentable and
professional and I just presented it and
I was in a heat with him and he got
priority,
which means that he had first right of
wave and I just needed a tiny little
score to win and he basically sat on me,
which means he uses it.
He used his priority to chase me around
the lineup and sit on me and keep me
from cutting a wave and let the time run
out.
And the whole time I was like,
you surf like a girl?
He served for like a little bitch.
Like I was like totally shit talking to
him.
And did it work?
Did he get you?
He got me because he wrote the I,
I,
I basically cracked and started like
getting emotional and he loved it.
He went,
I got this guy beat.
He started to shit talk me.
He loved that.
I any,
any,
uh,
he actually came up to me later and he
goes,
I love it that you're that passionate.
I love it that you got that site.
And that emotional where you just
started,
like trying to like insult me.
He's like,
that's my goal when I'm in heats with
people is to get them to that point.
You know?
It must like,
that's good.
There's got to be a lot of parallels.
The fight world,
right?
Yeah.
Well it's also when,
when you can get someone emotional than
fighting in particular is so dangerous.
And so when you lose,
you're not just losing like someone's
taking a piece of you,
you know,
because they're fucking you up.
They're not.
It's not just beating you on points.
I mean there are beating on point
sometimes,
but they're punching you in the face to
beat you on those points here,
the kicking you in the body,
they're fucking your legs up.
There's,
there's something about that that's so
intensely emotional.
So when you're fighting,
you're fighting at your best.
You have to be in this sort of flow
state,
this sort of Zen,
not thinking about anything but what's
happening and reacting and just going on
your training and your instincts.
And if you can get a guy to be angry and
emotional,
it will severely impair for most
fighters,
severely impair your ability to perform.
Most fighters,
they lose to get tense.
They tighten up,
they look to wind up instead of just
letting things flow.
We're talking about this guy style
bender who fought this weekend.
That guy follows like when you watch him
fight,
he just flows.
I mean he walks into the octagon
dancing.
Yeah,
I mean like full on dancing like pop in
and moving and has that mindset.
He's just,
he just gets loose and when he gets in
there,
he's switching stances and he's what?
What?
There was a mad shit talking session
between these two guys for the last six
weeks,
but he stayed calm through the whole
thing.
And you could when the two
gun into the octagon,
Derek Brunson just couldn't wait to just
grab a hold of them and style bender
just avoided all that shit.
And one of Kale and I'm in the first
round.
But the emotional aspect of the shit
talking and the,
the,
the tension that it brings because it
tightens guys up.
Like we were talking about bow hunting.
Like you see a big elk,
you have one shot at a big elk,
one shot,
you draw back your bow and you're like,
Holy Shit.
And it's literally a life or death
moment.
So there's all this tension.
And if you could alleviate that tension,
that pressure,
you will,
you would perform better.
The mindset is everything.
It's everything.
It's everything with golf,
it's everything with pool.
It's everything with any,
anytime there's something on the line.
But what's fascinating is like for you,
like you've watched thousands of fights
like ringside,
right?
Yeah,
sure.
So like you must be like,
hey,
we're in the second round and this guy
is,
you know,
these two guys are like up and up.
It's,
you know,
it's like a,
it's like a super tight fight and you
guys have a good fight and there must be
an inflection points where you instantly
know that one guy is going to lose.
Like something happens with their psyche
or something happens out there.
You can see in their eyes,
you can see it in their body language.
All of a sudden they lose that,
that edge,
that mindset,
and they are basically have already lost
even though it's like right in the
middle of the round.
So then you see one guy that's like the.
One of the crazy things about fighting
is it's so unpredictable.
Even when you think God is going to
lose,
sometimes they come back and win by
knockout,
like out of nowhere.
I just had a fight sport.
Who are those?
Yeah,
the guy with an awesome instagram.
Yeah.
Black Dude.
Dude.
He was losing that fight.
I'm not a fight nerd.
No,
he was getting fucked up.
He was Lou.
I'm like,
dude,
the guy's losing the fight.
There's zero chance to win next year.
No,
he,
yeah.
That was so exciting.
Volkov,
the guy he beat had just beaten for
overdoing who's a former heavyweight
champion.
Beat him by knockout.
So,
uh,
Alexander's the real deal.
I mean,
he's a.
He was what I thought was the dark horse
in the heavyweight division,
but he stood in front of Derek for too
long and derrick hit him with a fucking
bomb.
He had heard them earlier too because
derrick derrick hit him and knocked his
mouthpiece out and he didn't know his
mouthpiece was gone.
The referee was trying to get into the
Nazis.
He's like,
no,
that's not my mouthpiece.
That's his mouthpiece,
and the referee was like,
motherfucker,
you don't have a mouthpiece.
I'm holding your mouthpiece,
your mindset.
He's in the zone.
Dude.
I don't think he was in the zone.
I think he was in space.
That's that mindset of either had been
clipped,
but fighting like the nature of fighting
is built for competition.
It's perfectly suited to competition.
Surfing's not right surfing.
I think surfing is like the least suited
for competition.
I don't see surfing as a sport
whatsoever because when you're on the
wave,
you have to be zen.
You have to go with the flow of the
wave.
You're not really competing against
another person per se,
even though you are.
You're really riding the wave and you're
being judged.
Which is weird because it's artists,
I humans.
Yeah.
But I think the,
I think the single most important aspect
of surfing that makes it not good for
competition is you're dealing with
mother nature.
It's completely unfair.
Right?
Right,
right.
Like,
you might get an awesome wave.
The next guy might get a shitty one.
Yeah.
Some kid who on a scale of one to 10,
their ability levels like a three can
beat the Kelly slater in a heat easily
because it is just like if that kid gets
the best waves in the heat and Kelly
accidentally falls,
he loses,
you know,
like that's just the way it is.
Where like if I was playing,
you know,
Lebron James a thousand games in a row,
I'm never going to win.
Never gonna win.
It's impossible.
Um,
but I mean surf competitions,
cool that I,
I've surfing it just as a lifestyle as
like a way to stay sane and have peace
in your life and meet friends.
That's what surfing is about.
Servings.
Fucking awesome for that.
Do you think you appreciate it more now
that you're not competing?
Yeah,
I do because I don't see it as,
it's my,
My,
my surfing to me is tied to like only
happiness and only like surfing with my
son and his friends and surfing with my
daughter and going to the beach and,
and traveling to get epic waves.
It's not about like pressure and points
and a world title and sponsors putting
pressure on me and my me putting
pressure on myself that basically like
the,
the pressure part of surfing has gone,
which is amazing,
you know,
I still put the pressure on myself to
serve at a high level and perform at a
high level to myself.
Um,
and,
and you know,
and be able to,
you know,
have having a game still for sure.
I love that.
I love the,
I love the performance aspect of
surfing,
but the actual competition part is gone
for me.
It's so cool though that you kept the
love of it after the competition was
gone because one of the things that
happens to some,
what definitely happens to fighters,
they retire and they get fat.
They don't want to work out anymore
because the working out was so torturous
and it felt so much like work that after
it's over,
whatever love they had for martial arts
sort of goes out the window and they
start putting on weight.
They don't want to.
They don't want to train anymore,
but you even after the competition was
over,
you kept the love.
Yeah.
I just.
Surfing is this unique thing.
I don't know how you can fall out of
love with surfing.
Surfing,
surfing.
I.
When I'm in the front of the moment,
I stood on a surfboard and rubbed my
first wave.
I knew that was out.
That was who I was in my DNA.
Wow.
Like pure and simple.
This is.
This is why.
This is who I am.
First wave,
my yoga teachers become obsessed with
DNA,
with the DNA.
My Yoga teacher's been become obsessed
with surfing all over instagram now is
just surfing.
She just surfs everyday and it's so
weird not to nowhere and like 35 years
old.
She found surfing surfing's weird thing,
but it takes takes.
It's,
it's A.
There's not very many things that are,
that are really similar to surfing in
that way where you can fall in love with
it being five years old or 80 years old.
Well,
I would think being a yoga teacher too,
she's got incredible balance,
right?
Like having balanced probably really
help your ability to pick that up.
You know,
what's cool about surfing is it's,
is it's a,
you know,
like if I,
if I,
uh,
let's see if I,
if I take 100 people and said all you
guys are gonna learn how to drive a race
car and you had like a six week course,
just pure race car driving hundred.
The 100 of those people are going to
become really good at driving cars and
going super fast and racing and they'll
how this really accelerated learning
curve and get pretty damn good at it.
Snowboarding,
Yoga,
like almost anything surfing.
I like,
I know people who have been serving for
three decades and they suck.
I'm serious.
What is it?
They've never gotten a tube like in the
two.
That's like the,
that's like the Holy Grail of surfing,
like writing inside the waves,
like right in the center of it surfing's
fricking hard,
man.
It's like,
it has.
um,
I don't know.
It's,
it's uh,
but it doesn't mean you have to be good
to enjoy it.
Surfing's awesome.
No matter what level you're at.
And that's the beauty of surfing.
But surfing is hard to do,
man.
It's really hard to get good at.
So that's why you get people with
surfing,
you know,
five years and they're pretty good and
there's people who sort of 50 years and
they've never been good.
But what is,
what is it is a balance issue.
Is it,
um,
ability to adjust your,
your ability to correct while things are
happening.
Like what is it?
I think a lot of is body awareness and,
and,
and is adapting to something that's
changing all the time.
Like say it's like,
you know,
say for instance like basketball did
know the hoops,
they're the basketballs in your hands.
It's the elements never changed.
There's no variables really besides some
dude tried to block it or,
or golf.
You've got the club,
you got the ball,
he got the whole,
but with with surfing,
you got your board and you got you,
but that waves never the same.
There's literally never want to waves,
not the same to any others in the world,
and so every single time you're adapting
to things that are changing in the real,
in real time,
like up to the millisecond,
the waves changing shape as you're
writing insecure,
so you're never like reacting to
something that is going to stay put.
You're like anticipating the wave
changing shape and that's what you're
going to like.
I'm going to do a bottom turn into a big
turn on aerial maneuver or whatever it
is,
but you're not reacting to something
that's happening now.
You're reacting to the future.
Does that make sense?
Yeah,
it does make sense.
Now,
if I was a guy who had been surfing for
30 years and I sucked and I was friends,
we would still love it still.
Yeah,
surfing's awesome.
You can be the biggest Kook in the world
and have the most fun.
That's why surfing's is that when
someone who sucks,
what's called a Kook?
No,
I'm a quick look.
Who is someone who has,
who has no awareness in the water,
uh,
that's really what a cookie is like,
like if like,
if I'm out there surfing and I'm sitting
out there and I'm waiting for a wave and
you paddle out and I've been waiting for
a wave or a long time or some,
some,
some girl,
year old girls out there serving and
she's been waiting for,
you know,
15,
20 minutes and you paddle out and you
paddle,
right?
Pastor.
And the next way that comes in,
you just turn around and go,
you're a Kook.
Okay.
So that's,
that's if you're unaware of the
situation.
Yeah.
That's just,
that's how people get in fights surfing,
right?
Which is common.
Yeah.
Um,
well a lot of surfers are really into
Jujitsu.
Probably pretty dangerous to pick a
fight with a surfer.
Oh yeah.
What does that.
One guy's named Joel,
uh,
from Hawaii.
From San Diego with the old tutor.
Yes.
He's a Brazilian jujitsu black belt.
He is.
Yeah.
And you would never know it.
He,
yeah,
he looks like so unassuming.
He looks like a guy who fixes computers.
He is,
he's,
and he's a Stoney Bologna.
Super Skinny,
hippie cruisy dude,
like stony eyes,
but he'll fuck you up.
He will fuck you up.
But he's cool,
man.
He's,
he's awesome.
And he's an incredible surfer,
incredible surfer.
I've seen some footage of him surf,
amazing style and stuff,
but he's,
he's,
um,
he's very unassuming.
Joel,
his Jujitsu is super legit too.
Yeah,
I've talked to people that have trained
with him.
He's super legit.
He'll tell you a real quick.
I would imagine that from that
background,
like surfing and that body awareness and
the ability to adjust and change.
That's one of the things about Jujitsu
is like every role is different.
Your,
you have your rolling with different
people,
different size people and your ability
to adjust and change is always changing.
There's always movement.
So he's exactly right.
Adapt that weirdness of the movement.
So Jujitsu and surfing or you know,
they totally have their similarities
because you're,
you're sort of anticipating the guys
next move,
which is very similar to surfing on the
wave,
you know,
reacting to what that guys going to do
in the future.
Not to what happening.
Right.
That very second,
right?
A lot of times if I was a guy that had
been surfing for 30 years and I sucked
and I knew you,
I'd be like,
Hey Shane,
Dorian,
what the fuck am I doing wrong?
How do I fix this?
Yeah.
I don't know.
Is there fixing servings?
Not like golf where you,
where you need to get better all the
time.
Hmm.
You know what I'm saying?
Like,
like,
like if you can enjoy it even if you
suck,
is that what you mean?
Like if you're a golfer and you and your
[inaudible] I'm not a golfer,
but if you're a golfer and your average
game is like an 82,
and I said,
Joe,
if you buy this putter for a thousand
dollars,
your average score will be an 80.
You're going to buy that,
that putter because it's the freaking
world to you to shave two strokes off
your game.
That's the biggest thing in the world to
improve.
No one gives a shit if they're slightly
better at surfing is all you care about
is like the is like waking up at the
crack of dawn and having your coffee
cruise down to the beach,
seeing the waves and reading the tides
and the wind and the and like going
surfing with your buddies and having fun
and then you go get breakfast and get
some breakfast tacos and go to work.
That's the lifestyle is like keeps
people sane.
That's why they do it.
They don't do it to get better or surf
super good at or go really fast and that
stuff's fun.
But I mean I don't have any more fun
than a guy who serves.
Have as good as me.
We have the same run,
but I bet he wishes he could surf as
good as you.
Yeah,
for sure.
So,
and I wish I served as good as the best
stuff on earth,
but it doesn't make it more fun,
which is,
that's,
that's why I love surfing.
That's so cool.
That's fascinating.
So what does it make it more?
If you want to get better at it,
if it doesn't make it more fun,
what does it make it more?
It does something.
It doesn't make it more fun.
Does it make it more satisfying if
you're better at it,
like when you surf at a high level,
which is important to you,
now it gives you more options because
the waves get big.
Right?
Which makes it more fun.
So it's really difficult to surf really
big waves with,
with really low ability.
Right?
So when the waves get big and really
heavy and technical,
you can't go out there and unless you
have really good ability to level like
in,
unless you have a high ability level,
you really can't perform in really great
great conditions.
Right?
So like when you see the crazy
conditions were that you guys get towed
out and you ride those 80 foot waves,
that shit.
No one who's goofy's doing that?
There's some goofy guys doing that
because you're using machines to tell
you in the waves.
Is that you?
Jesus.
Shane.
Oh fuck.
That just gives me such anxiety watching
this.
How big is that wave?
Uh,
I dunno.
Probably Sixty feet on the face of
start.
Damn son.
Oh,
what does that feel like right there
when it's over.
This part's cool.
Watch.
I get air on the way down.
Oh my God.
See my board because completely an error
right there.
Do you are so high.
That is so high.
Is so giant.
It's like 40 feet above your head right
now.
Oh my God.
This gives me anxiety.
You know what's cool about surfing is in
those moments,
like there's very few things in the
world other than like,
I don't know.
I don't know how to relate that,
but I'm like,
that moment right there for me was like
the pinnacle of like who I am,
what I do best.
That moment,
that wave coming in at that,
at that minute in my life where I was in
a right square foot of the ocean,
when that wave came in,
that was Beth.
That was one of the best days in history
at that of spot.
Wow.
Um,
and I was there.
I was prepared.
I was healthy.
Have the right board,
the right equipment,
the right energy level.
I wasn't sick.
I didn't have any,
you know,
everything was just lined up and the
waves are lined up and the swell was
lined up and the wind was line up and
the tide was lined up and I was in a
perfect spot when that wave came in.
Do you watch the video all the time?
No,
but every time I do,
I remember all those things because it
seems so much so,
so much luck had to do with it.
It's just like a line in the stars
aligning.
That almost seems like something I'd
want to watch every day.
Like,
get,
get the day going.
You know,
your first kiss from a girl.
That's what that is.
Wow.
That like mind blown.
Whoa,
this is,
this is like an important moment in my
life and I need to like have this moment
in time frozen.
That's what that is right there.
And so I think as an adult,
you very rarely have those moments left.
I mean,
I
really like mind expanding mind
exploding moments where you're like,
Holy Shit,
this is life 100 percent life right now,
and that's,
that's what I think we're all chasing.
You know what I mean?
Those people sitting in traffic outside
right now driving on the freeway,
they're not having those moments.
Not right then.
That's a real problem.
Yeah.
That's a real problem with life is that
people aren't having enough of those
moments
and when you're a 75 yards away from
that elc a few weeks ago and you had an
hour to to really think about what
you're doing and where you were in your
life and how you know how you got to 75
yards away from this animal to the whole
year of practicing on the target and all
the millions of arrows you shot and all
the preparation that isn't in this thing
stands up and time's ticking and that
moment is there for the taking and it's
so easy to fuck up and it.
It all happens the way that you.
You hope to visualize it.
Those moments don't happen very often,
man.
No they don't,
and that is what would a lot of people
like yourself or myself or chasing,
you're always chasing these,
these above average moments,
these high level moments,
these moments where it just.
Everything's elevated.
Yeah,
like when you're drawn back on a big
elk,
there's not another thing in your mind.
There's nothing on your mind other than
your shot execution and getting it done
and everything's heightened and all this
pressure around you.
Some guys shake,
like I've seen some guys drawn back on
an animal and that their arms are
shaking like they're shaking.
Yeah.
Like did you see it in everything?
So much anticipation that could barely
keep it together.
I mean,
that's what target panic is,
right?
It's like there's all this freak out.
Just different.
You know,
there's,
there's
a lot of different levels.
Yeah.
Well I've seen guys do that where they
had a perfect shot opportunity,
animal standing 20 yards away.
Broadside exactly what you pray for and
they get into the shakes and you have to
let down,
let down.
Wow.
Didn't even take a bad shot.
They'd let down and just got.
I can't do it.
Just too much anxiety.
It's probably better than shooting.
Oh,
that's much better.
Yeah,
for sure.
Smart.
Yeah,
that's,
that's an aware person.
Yeah,
it is.
But I mean,
I think human beings are meant to have a
lot of those kinds of experiences.
Those experiences make life richer and
more satisfying.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Sounds like two people who love animals
like,
oh,
you piece of shit.
You want to kill an animal that makes
life better.
It's not that like you're,
you're eating meat no matter what.
I feel better when I eat meat.
I believe it's healthier.
Have had these discussions with
nutritionists and scientists and I just
think it's better for you.
I really do.
And for me to get it that way is way
better because I'm getting my meat along
with this insane hobby that's super
difficult to do.
I mean I could go out and just shoot a
bunch of pigs with a rifle and I could
get my meat that way and it would still
be fun.
It would still be thrilling.
It would still be ethical.
Wouldn't be the same though.
Is it not the same experience?
No.
I mean,
do you,
do you want 100 percent?
Just for meat.
You can get me to the store.
Like the experience of that,
of those moments out there with your
friends and the under the pressure and,
and,
and just putting yourself in that
position where you like,
you need to make it count.
That's right.
That's part of our human existence.
That's part of what makes life worth
living is,
is his habit.
Having to,
I don't even know,
but just were like,
you know,
um,
I don't know,
but yeah,
I know what you mean.
You can get me to the store,
but you can get wild elk at the store
and you can't get it that way.
There's just such a giant difference
between your relationship with the meat
that you're eating.
When I take an elk steak out of the
freezer and defrost it and I season it,
your food looks amazing by the way.
Like really,
really good at it.
Yeah.
They are getting good at it.
The week after you were in an elk camp
and Utah,
we were there with Chad Ward,
a whiskey whiskey bent barbecue on
instagram.
Who's a master chef.
He's a fucking wizard.
He's a pitmaster winds like those world
championships.
And he taught me how to cook it
properly.
That was awesome.
And you know,
it's all about doing it slow and then
searing it afterwards and you just
maintain all the people threw that up.
Everybody.
Yeah.
Even one of the guides,
one of the guides was talking to me
about,
you know,
who said wild game is kind of tough.
And we're like,
well how are you cooking?
It was like,
well I'll just throw it on the grill.
Like,
okay,
you can't do that.
You can't just do it on high heat,
high heat.
Basically sear it and then serve it.
This is not Sashimi,
right?
Well you can if you do it real thin,
slice it crazy thin.
Yeah.
You can click.
It's not bad,
but it's way better if you do a low and
slow.
I've brought it down to 2:25
now I like to cook it at 2:25.
Yeah,
I just set it at 2:25
and I'll,
I'll cook a,
an elk steak for fucking an hour,
you know,
whatever.
It's a trigger.
Yeah.
Because you.
If you set a trigger to 25 users setting
called super smoke and so just fills
that,
the inside of those things are so good
for wild game.
It really fast it.
Yeah,
it's all just.
The beautiful thing about them is the
people don't know what we're talking
about.
A trigger is a pellet grill and these
pellet grills like this tables made out
of Oak,
right?
When they cut this table,
they would take the sawdust from this
table and they compress it and just
using the natural sugars in the woods.
They create these pellets and then these
pellet grills,
they have these,
a worm drives that feed these pellets
into a heating element and the heating
element,
it just,
it just gets hot and then fire and then
a fan blows in the fire to keep the fire
going and it's all computer controlled
so it calculates exact same temperature
and it maintains that temperature.
It's so good,
but it's just so pure.
It's just wood and fire.
No Gas,
no.
No chemicals like on charcoal briquettes
or no bullshit,
so it tastes so good off the things.
Every time I.
Every time I have people over at my
house and I cook wild game on my
trigger,
I have these people like,
what the hell I need to get one of these
things.
I've made lots of sold like a million of
them right now.
Once you learn how to cook with them and
learn how to do it correctly,
they have those little ones.
Especially wild game.
Wild game is really easy to screw up and
it's really hard to screw it up on a
trigger really because of the fact that
it doesn't have much fat in it.
Yeah,
it doesn't dry it out.
Doesn't cook out though.
You know the moisture and the right.
Do you take yours afterwards and set it
in a cooler to let it rest?
I don't do that.
That's next level.
Is it excellent.
I'm getting gems here.
Gold.
This is from Dudley.
He does is.
He'll sear it and then he'll cover it
with aluminum foil and put it in a
trigger or put it in a Yeti.
Rather.
Put it in a cooler clothes seal that
cooler up for like 10 minutes.
And what's in the cooler besides the
meat?
Nothing.
There's no like a little like ice
packard and like that'd be nice.
You don't want to just let it sit.
It's actually still cooking so I let it
sit.
I let it sit,
but I don't,
I don't wrap it up.
And if you wrap it in aluminum foil and
then let it sit inside the cooler,
the cooler actually allows it to
continue coaching just a little bit.
Okay.
So how many degrees do you take it out
before?
One 15.
I like to take it out at 1:15.
Then I see her the outside of it and
then I seal it up with aluminum foil and
then I put it in the Yeti and I let it
sit in that Yeti for 10 minutes.
So it's continuing to slowly,
slowly.
Because if you take something warm and
you put it in the Yeti,
it'll keep it warm.
Yeah.
If you take something called it just
insulate and incredibly fantastically
insulated.
And so it works with heat or with cold.
All right.
I'm going to try it.
I talked to Doug,
he's the wizard at this stuff,
you know,
I mean,
and he's constantly cooking wild game.
He essentially,
that's all he does.
A good cook.
So very good cook.
Yeah.
Have you ever been to.
It should be.
She freaking does a lot of hunting.
He better be doing a to cook and to.
Yeah,
he just drove all the way from Oklahoma
to Kansas.
He,
he shot a deer in Kansas,
drove from or not Kansas,
Oklahoma.
Shot a deer in Oklahoma,
drove all through the night in Oklahoma
and parked his truck and got into a,
a blind in Iowa.
I mean,
he just lives it and he's hard core.
He's as hardcore as you get.
Yeah,
but that's all he eats.
I mean he's,
he's constantly eating deer and cooking
deer and he loves cooking for other
people are like large groups of friends
and family and he's always cooking and
entertaining.
I,
I love that about him.
Like when he cooked for 10 of us.
Yeah.
That was awesome.
Incredible meals and everything was well
games.
It's frigging awesome.
That Lanai trip,
man,
I look forward to that every year.
It's like a highlight of my year,
you know,
what are we doing it this year?
I know,
right?
We got to talk with you.
GotTa.
You gotta talk dates.
We've got to figure out the dates
because that last year was so amazing to
have everybody down there and you know,
everybody is such a good crew.
So fucking cool.
You know,
green tree and cam and.
Yeah,
it's just awesome.
And then the first,
first year we invented the cat lady
drink.
Yeah.
That
one.
Yeah.
That was ridiculous.
I think Dudley might be still drinking
it.
I don't think anybody else has died off.
Red Bull and wine.
And what was it?
Tequila.
That was the lab a little bit ambitious.
So that was a fucking nasty because it
definitely was a deadly concoction.
Yeah,
he was already hammered.
He was just rated my mini bar.
Just take whatever's in.
There is like a mad scientist at
liquors,
isn't he?
He's not afraid.
That was such a fun podcast.
So we're all just enjoy it.
It's something about Lanai to where you
can hunt in paradise and it's such a
small island.
It's like you'd use,
there's not very many people there.
The whole island,
last 3000 humans and shitload a deer.
It's crazy around every Bush scene it
seems like sometimes.
Yeah,
that's a great thing is it's so easy to
screw up hunting those access deer,
especially with a bow that it's so neat
to go and like find your Arrow and then
you know,
five minutes later you got a whole
nother group of stock.
That's awesome.
Well,
it's also the most ethical form of
hunting because they literally need to
be hunted.
They have to be.
They don't have any predators.
It's a.
and it's not something that some person
who was a greedy person said,
oh,
I'm going to put all these deer in the
silent.
Then I'm going to go hunt them.
Now they were brought there for a gift
for King Kamehameha in the 18 hundreds
and it doesn't take a wildlife biologist
to tell you that the numbers will get
out of hand if you don't hunt them.
Yeah.
Like when you're there,
it's really obvious.
That's a perfect example of,
of,
of how somewhere needs to be managed.
Yeah,
and I know those guys on Maui have that
project going on where they're hunting
deer and then giving the meat to poor
people,
which is the best meat in the world.
I mean it's such an accident right here
is so delicious and that's a great
program.
It's a fantastic program.
What is the name of that?
It's got some.
That's a.
that's Jake Muse and like a Hickey knew
he project.
Yeah,
that's the name he knew he project.
See you're from Hawaii.
You can spit those words out my mouth.
Yeah,
it's funny.
It's a.
You should have jake on the show.
He's,
he's a,
he's a really good dude and he's got
some great stories and he's really well
educated and knows this business really
well.
So he started meat company.
Yeah.
So he does eradication in Hawaii because
it needs to be done and needs to be
managed.
So.
And they're on Maui.
Yeah.
And so he,
you know,
he wanted to,
to be able to actually utilize that meat
because he,
you know,
these big ranches and golf courses and
stuff,
they,
they actually pay him to come in there
and do it and so he actually flipped it
and figured out a way to start a neat
company.
So it's like a win win situation because
the deer need to be managed and you
know,
he's feeding people and then the Kikino
he projects totally different.
Like he doesn't have a meat company for
that,
but he's able to harvest the animals in
a really good way and then he's able to
utilize that meet by giving it to
families who need it.
Simple as that.
It's just phenomenal.
And it's great.
Again,
it's meat that people would pay a
shitload of money for.
It would be like if,
if,
if you could buy commercially raised
access dear,
it would be one of the prized meets
because it's such an unusual flavor.
It's extremely delicious.
And people that don't like wild game and
they were like,
oh,
I'm not really into Venice and I would
like to cook access to care for them.
I'd be like,
just let me cook this for you and tell
me what you think because I've cooked it
for like,
I cooked it from my mother in law and
she,
she was,
she like took one bite of it and raise
her eyebrows.
And she goes,
what is this?
I'm like,
it's access dear.
She's like,
what kind of direction?
I hadn't showed her a picture of it.
She says,
if this is unbelievable,
so delicious.
It's cool to baffle somebody with wild
game.
Yeah,
if you,
if you can cook it right.
Especially access drgs.
That's incredible.
And how beautiful they are.
They just in general walking around and
then we'd get one.
They're like,
I don't know.
It's just incredible animals.
I think they're my favorite.
The favorite to hunt?
Yeah.
Well what I like about them is we
generally go on this access to your
haunt like a couple of months for elk
season.
So you get all the jitters out of the
way because they are,
they are like seven times faster than
you think.
An animal that size can be like when
they move you like how did you,
how did it even do that?
Like how does something move that fast?
It's that didn't straighten matrix,
straight matrix and the access to
arrows.
I'm probably going to Piss some people
off by saying this,
but the axis deer in Hawaii or different
axis deer in Hawaii or different Benny
O'bryan when we're on the NIH and he was
hunting access to her,
he had.
It was very challenging,
very,
very challenging.
They were ducking arrows and matrices.
Just he was having a hard time and he
went back to.
He went back home,
back to Texas,
back to the drawing board and said,
I got.
I got,
I got to go hunting.
He went and hunted access deer first
morning,
shot a huge buck and he called me.
He goes,
I shot a huge buck,
and he goes,
but I got to tell you,
they're fucking different in Texas.
Did the deer just don't react the same
way?
I mean,
in,
in Hawaii,
Hawaiians,
there's no season,
they're,
the Hawaiians are eating that meat 365
days a year.
They're,
they're hunting them with high powered
rifles all year long.
My Maui,
Molokai,
Ella and I,
and uh,
those deer are,
they just react like crazy.
Yeah.
They're living in hell every day.
The Paradise,
but living in paradise,
it's also a hell.
Every day they're getting shot at.
There's,
there's a good reason they're paranoid.
Yeah.
I mean,
Dan said in Texas,
they were just like head down feeding
children.
They had no idea.
He was like,
dude,
it's like a different breed.
But he was also there during the Rut to
get a little bit more relaxed during the
rough.
Sure.
They're switched on in Texas,
but in,
in,
in Hawaii,
they're hyper switched on.
If anybody ever wanted to understand
human biology,
like male versus female biology,
they should see deer and elk in the Rut.
Yup.
To see animals in the Rut that normally
would be super spooky,
afraid of everything jumping at every
snap twig and they just walking right up
to people like they don't know what's
going on there in a horny for you get
you ever see that video of the guy who
taps the deer on the antlers with as
well as Arrow?
He's got an arrow and this deer in front
of him.
He just tapped on the antlers.
The deer is like,
what?
Yeah,
well I think that would ever happen.
It wasn't right in the meeting season
once.
Once they get those throbbing boners
they don't know what the fuck's going
on.
Just wandering around.
I saw an elk actually having sex this
year.
You ever seen that in real life?
Up Close?
Like not through binoculars.
Yeah.
So it was only like 30 yards and it's
elk and they met.
They get up in mount and then they go
back one big thrust.
Yeah.
I was like,
that's how they get down.
Like that's crazy.
That's crazy.
It's literally like our double.
Yes.
And he was so proud of himself and he
got down and he was just like,
Shit.
Yes.
Got that moved on.
There was like 20 other 20 other
calories right there that he had the.
He had the service.
That's ridiculous.
Just wandering around.
Yeah,
I saw it from about 60 yards out.
It sounds crazy,
right?
It's,
it's a fascinating experience to just to
be around them when they're behaving
like that.
They're screaming and yelling at each
other and,
and running and mating.
It's because it only happens once a year
for those animals.
Oh,
we're gonna.
See it right here on top.
It's very climactic.
I would wonder how accurate it is.
It's got to be here,
man.
I got to line it up.
Yeah,
I,
he just didn't align in that up.
I guess he's lining it up,
but does he really know what he's doing?
He only does it once every six months or
once every 11 months.
Let's be frustrating on.
You can see why they'll fight each other
for it.
They run for about a month,
right?
Yeah.
But how cool is it?
How one bowl,
if he's a bad ass.
And a good fighter,
he can have like the first bull that I
actually arrowed with my bow,
he had a Harem of 45 cows,
one bowl and there was like three
satellite bulls,
but there was one bowl and he had 45
cows with him that he was hurting that
were his girlfriends.
And they're all basically in heat.
Yeah.
So they're,
they're like relying on him to service
all of them.
40th five cows.
And I,
from what I hear,
there's places where it's like there's
like one bowl for 80 cows.
It's crazy.
It's a lot of work.
It's too exhausting.
You really want like three.
That's like,
that's like Dan Bilzerian,
he's like a human bowl boil.
Very similar isn't that is fucking logo.
Did you have him on your show?
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
So good.
He's always invited me to parties and
I'm like,
listen man,
I'm married.
I can't go to your fucking pointless.
Pointless to go to a party of his.
If you're married.
I think his,
his logo was a bowl.
Not a bull elk,
but a bowl because it go.
Is it a goat to go?
Really?
Yeah,
I think so.
So yeah,
it does it go.
It's like who's your move lawn,
right?
That's what it looks like.
I moved onto the sheet,
but yeah,
that's a goat I think.
Hmm.
But uh,
so is a super random
who's the best podcast you've ever had?
Every time I think I have the best
podcasts,
we'll have another one that's better.
I talked to someone that I respect
recently and they said that the Elan
Musk one was the best podcast ever.
It's pretty damn good in history.
Yeah.
That one is wherever.
The best podcasts in history.
That's a strong word.
Best podcasts ever been made.
Well,
he's such a unique mind mean he just.
So they just,
he just posted a video of one of the
boring tunnels,
first a completed tunnels.
And so the.
Let's see Jamie on.
Yeah,
it's an insanely long tunnel through La
and they,
they've been doing this only for a few
months,
but apparently in December they're going
to start doing this.
Like,
look how long this is.
This is inside La.
I mean this is his actual completed real
tunnel.
That's underneath la right now.
Kay,
can we talk about how there's no like,
like a,
like a prototype that we heard about is
like all of a sudden he was just like,
ah,
how do you get a.
Who owns the land underneath?
That's a real good question.
I don't think he understood what I was
asking when I asked him that.
I'm like,
how do you,
how do you do this?
Like who do you ask to do this?
Like all of a sudden he called my
project manager.
I'm like no shit house to make a well
and they want to dig under their house
to make a well and they'd go through the
roof of your tunnel.
Are they allowed to.
I love that there's humans like him that
are thinking on such a massive scale
that are trying to fix the biggest
problems that humans are facing.
Guys like you were out there riding
waves and I'm telling Dick Jokes.
This guy is digging holes under the
earth.
Yeah.
I mean he's also sending cars in the
space.
Right?
He sent his own car.
He shot into space.
He's got space x.
he's talking about colonizing Mars,
he's got a Tesla company that makes the
best electric cars on the planet earth.
I mean,
he's got so many different things going
on simultaneously.
I just don't understand his capacity for
work.
He's trying,
he's trying to fix the energy,
you know,
the energy problem with,
getting energy from,
from the sun to power your house to
power your car to power cities and you
know,
it's crazy.
He makes solar panels now that are
actually tiles for your roof or your
solar roof.
Incredible.
Like you replaced the tiles on your roof
with these solar time.
Solar's fricking cool dude.
I just got it on my house.
I got,
I got it on my house and it and have one
of those tests,
the powerwall two batteries and things
insane.
And it's got like this crazy smart
algorithm that knows when a hurricane's
coming to Hawaii and it'll like power up
my,
my battery deal 100 percent.
Even if I'm not home,
even if I'm not watching the weather
channel,
it just does it automatically because it
knows it might need to back up my house.
Wow,
so my,
all,
my elk doesn't go bad in my freezer.
So are you on the grid?
Are you off the grid on the grid,
but you have the solar power as well as
a backup power comes from
the,
the solar and you could sell some of it
back to the grid.
No,
mind you that.
they used to do that in Hawaii,
but I think they stopped in the power
companies weren't down with solar
really.
It's hard to establish solar.
It's hard to get permits and everything
to have your house set up.
Like they,
they try to make it kind of difficult
for it.
Try to make it very difficult.
Yeah.
But I,
it's pretty cool.
I've,
I've offset my,
my,
my power needs with solar by like 80
percent.
Wow,
that's great.
So you could conceivably just exists
purely on solar.
Yeah.
Now you're on the big island.
Yup.
No wild is fucking crazy.
Volcano Shit is going.
How's that?
You freaking out about that at all?
Not freaking out.
I was freaking out.
Yeah.
So,
so I live on the west side in Kona.
The volcanoes on the east side.
So is the east side,
is that near?
Just south of Hilo.
Okay.
And that's where the,
the,
that's where the volcano was,
but the wind like the tradewinds blow
east to west.
So.
So where I live,
it looked like Shanghai for like three
months.
The air sucked like crazy.
It was like La smog times 10.
That freaked me out.
I just pulled up vog bog vogue like.
Yeah,
like,
like volcanic hayes.
My daughter is severely allergic to
that.
Really?
Yeah.
We went to a store on the big island.
We were staying at the four seasons and
we left and went down to a store to get
something for a cell phone.
She came with me and she just starts
sneezing and sniffling and her eyes were
puffing up.
I'm like,
UK,
like,
what's going on?
Are you sick?
She's like,
I don't know what's going on.
And the guy at the counter said,
oh,
it's probably the vog.
And I said,
what the fuck is the Vog is volcanic
smog?
And it just didn't bother me at all.
But with her,
she's allergic to cats and a couple
other things like make her sniffle.
It was bad for about three months where
I live.
It's horrible.
Yeah,
that's what it looks like.
That's insane.
That does look like it looks like
Beijing,
you know.
And the crazy thing was,
you know,
like if the,
if the,
if the wind goes the wrong way,
then like Maui Allahu,
it's all foggy,
like all throughout Hawaii.
But it was basically like the whole,
uh,
the volcano essentially at a crazy
eruption for about three and a half
months.
Yeah.
And then not digit stopped.
And the air quality is incredible.
Where I live now.
Real?
Yeah.
Just so blue off blue skies,
crystal clear,
like just insane.
Sunset sunrises.
Uh,
it's just beautiful.
So what did geologists best air quality
in 10 years for sure.
Yeah.
Why is that?
I don't know because there was like a
constant interruption for like 25 years,
but it was just kind of small,
but it was continuously going.
But now it's like nearly shut down
completely.
So there's hardly any kind of anything
going in the air.
So the volcano blew its load.
Did kinda like that elk?
Yeah.
Bang.
It was.
It was lining us up for awhile and just
big old bank.
So the Vog is gone.
So now it's probably a good time to go
there.
It's a very good time.
Wow.
Come over and visit.
Does it fuck with the.
That's why I texted you and said come
over and hunt.
We're going hunting.
I ain't getting hit in the head by a
giant chunk of lava.
Oh my God.
Dude.
Did you hear about the fricken boat that
had a big like a lava rock,
like a boulder lava boulder.
And go through the roof of it.
Yeah.
There's like a spectator boat.
They were a tourist boat watching the
volcano psycho there.
They were so close.
Yeah.
Do you have a soda that Jamie that you
can bring up?
It's nuts.
These tour boat companies,
if they're.
They're pretty opportunistic.
You know,
it's not,
it's not easy to make a living on the
big island.
And so you get these people that all
want to go see the eruption.
That all the lava going into the water.
Oh,
if you can look for a photo of the boat
near the eruption,
there's some images of these boats that
were like,
it looked like they were like 50 feet
away from this mega eruption.
Like crazy.
Really scary stuff.
But you don't have to mess with lava
man.
Yeah,
and especially when it's spitting things
out as the year before that watches
molten rock,
the earth pissed.
That's when it happened to veer off the
coast of Hawaii's big island.
Monday.
Well back then a buyer.
I want to watch it fly through the air
and hit them and I will think what would
I do?
Look at it flying into the air.
The time to think about what you would
do is before you get on the boat.
Yeah.
Once you're in that boat,
you're.
You're just locked in.
Dude.
That's crazy.
The whole on the fucking boat roof,
you see the redness and the whole of the
boat.
Just the hot shit just tore right
through the roof.
Well,
and all,
all of these tour boat guys are
competing right there.
They're like jockeying for position to
get the closest,
unobstructed view so everyone can take
videos and posted on their instagram.
Wow,
but you're 23 people injured.
Okay.
Let's talk about if one of those like
little like lava nuggets.
Just having a flight to you just blow
right through you.
Yeah.
What if it hit someone in the head?
How about the guy next to you?
It's headless and you're sitting there
with your fucking camera out trying to
get a selfie for instagram,
but the thing is that everybody trips
out and like,
oh my God,
is this unprecedented?
Is Lava just,
can you believe this lava volcanoes
happening?
I'm like,
are you kidding me?
We live on an active volcano.
That's where we live.
I born and raised on this island
erupting almost every day since I was
born.
True,
right?
Yeah.
Most of your life that is interrupting.
Yup.
Yeah.
You can go almost anytime of the year,
any year and see lava.
Pretty cool.
Kona,
because terrence Mckenna used to live in
Kona is is that you don't know who turns
candidate.
He's a very famous psychedelic,
I guess you would call them a
psychedelic speaker.
Scholar.
He's a,
he was a botanist who I'm an
ethnobotanist
who set up this place and Kona and uh,
he was,
uh,
he was off the grid completely off the
grid.
Like he has Iowasca oh yeah.
Camp,
everything.
He,
he,
he had his,
I don't know what,
what's going on with his old property,
but I think some of it burnt down.
There was a fire up there and I think he
lost like,
oh no,
no,
no.
The fire was up in northern California.
He had some of his books up in northern
California,
but he has a place up in the big island
that there was like 30 different types
of psychedelic plants growing on his,
you know,
and like 10 acres up there.
That's a spot up there.
And he had been in that house high as a
kite or.
Well,
no,
I'm friends with his brother.
I would like to go there.
He's dead now,
unfortunately.
Really?
Yeah.
It looks like a pretty frequent cosmic
joint right there.
Well,
that's a weird picture,
right?
It looks very.
See that picture?
Yeah.
He had a dope place so he would get all
his water from the rain.
He would.
He had like these cisterns,
I guess they would call them what do
these containers that catch rainwater
and he had a everything filtered that
way and say horny hippies a,
there's probably some freaky shit going
on up there,
late night activities of,
but he was doing a lot of lectures on
psychedelics and school,
one of the most influential speakers
ever on psychedelics because he was so
interesting.
Such an interesting guy to listen to.
A lot of people like that really
gravitate to the big island.
Yeah.
There's something about the big island
where we live that has just.
It's alive.
It really is.
The island is fricking alive.
Yeah,
and you feel that there's like this,
there's like an energy there and there's
people who are like,
I'm meant to live here.
I had moved across the earth to live
here because it's like just pulled me
here,
meet people like that all the time.
Did your brick and he's one of those
guys.
I mean he's from Colorado.
He was originally from Colorado,
but I mean for him he was a bit of a
recluse and he would fly six for six
months of the year.
He would fly and give these lectures in
Austin and San Francisco and all over
the world really,
and then he would fly back and live on
the big island to write books and the
cool place to live.
Man,
it's awesome.
I love living there and if you're a bow
hunter,
so in a bad place either.
Right?
It's not a bad place either.
Why isn't incredible for awning boss?
This is incredible for people.
Everybody's got a really good attitude
there.
It's like it's more,
you know,
I just got back from Manhattan,
which I love a logo in New York City
and.
But every time I go there I'm like,
I don't think I could do this.
I don't think I could live here.
It's just two stacked on top of things.
And there was this one thing that I had
seen there that I'd never seen before.
They had like this rotating,
rotating machine that you parked cars
on.
So say if you parked your car in here
with lift up like this and then your car
would go like up here and then
underneath there and be like 30 cars
underneath you.
I was like,
what the fuck is that?
I see not in Tokyo.
Crazy dude.
That's.
And You can rent one of those spots.
One of those,
one of those car spots for like
huge bucks in Tokyo.
I'm sure like 50 grand a year will
tougher like for,
for like a parking spot at your building
where you live.
Have you been to Tokyo?
Yeah.
Lots.
So condensed.
Yeah.
It's such a strange.
It's another Tokyo strange too because
it's so polite.
Yeah.
I love Tokyo.
It's like everyone's.
It's almost like you're visiting an
alien culture because I don't
understand.
I don't know what they're writing is.
I see it but I recognize it as Japanese
but I have no idea what it says.
And then the people there,
they're all like super polite and very
orderly and then everything's electronic
and it's almost like times square,
like with big,
like this is almost like a,
like a parallel civilization.
Like on another planet and how the hell
they get there.
That's where they ended up.
Like if you look at the history of
Japan,
it's the opposite of that.
Right?
Right.
Means true old school,
Japan.
It's the opposite of that.
Like all of a sudden they have like this
full on,
like forward technology,
hyper futuristic civilization there now.
Yeah.
That's a fascinating thing about Asian
period,
right?
Like Samsung in Korea,
they make the,
some of the best electronics in the
world and you drive just outside the
city and there's like rice fields
everywhere and people weren't,
you know,
working with those cool hats on and like
everyone has no shoes and just on their
new mud.
Then you drive right to the city and
it's just like this giant electronic
city.
Yeah.
Wonder what it is.
Kind of cool.
Good food though in Japan and all over
Asia,
but I love Japan.
Dig It.
No,
Japan's pretty.
I'm just fascinated by the culture
period.
I mean that's obviously the birthplace
of a lot of martial arts.
Judo came from their karate.
A lot of.
Whoa.
A lot of,
a lot of.
I'm not the exact thing you want to be
spilling into the crack.
I was afraid that we're going to have
nothing to talk about that was going to
be interesting or we get stuck on like
our tree for like two hours.
So I looked up a couple of things.
What did you look up?
I was looking.
I was geeking out in the car.
Was that impressive when I just pulled
up in like a big Old Cadillac bug?
A black cadillac with a driver or what?
No,
it's normal.
Everybody does.
That was really,
really weird.
Weird view because you live in Hawaii.
Yeah.
Don't do that very often.
But when you drive like a Tundra,
some shit I do.
I drive a Toyota Tundra from big on a
Toyota.
Every bloody in Hawaii has a Toyota kill
break.
This fricken state car.
It's the move,
right?
They don't break.
They don't.
I've had three lexuses,
Lexus Suv.
Those fucking things never break down.
They never have a single thing.
Goldwater.
Amazing.
Nothing.
No.
They're incredible vehicles.
Yeah.
They just won't.
And,
and you know in,
in Hawaii you're going off road so much
that.
Yeah,
I,
for surfing and hunting,
I'm always going off road and campaign,
taking my kids and stuff.
So you want something reliable and you
can fricking.
You can buy a Toyota truck for like 35
grand in like six years later.
You sell it for 32.
Yeah.
The resale values nuts and it'll go for
200,000
miles.
They're great with zero problems and
drive a big Tundra.
That's the other thing that Japanese
figured out how to do.
Like how they figure out how to make
things.
So God damn reliable.
Yeah.
You know,
is that you?
There's my truck.
Yes.
Look at that.
Lifted Toyota,
Hawaii.
That's my last truck.
I got the exact same truck now though
too.
Good truck.
Get anywhere you want to go.
Yeah.
I'm actually sponsored by the local
dealership where I live.
Oh really?
Big Island.
Toyota.
Shout out,
shout out to your Toyota.
We'll get the fender flares and
everything.
I thing is google drive straight up a
mountain or a bet it will.
And up hold about 10 deer in the back of
it.
Have you ever seen that company called a
Dev Rolo?
They take those things.
They make a bulletproof and they,
they,
uh,
they spray the outside of.
Um,
what,
what does that fucking coding that makes
some bulletproof?
I might need to get that for all the
Peta people.
Do you get paid?
People don't,
you don't get any hunting and surfing.
You would think that they're both.
You're actually natural,
but you'd get a little bit of it just
because there's a lot of Granola crunchy
people that get upset.
There was a lot of like dolphin writers
in the surf world that are like,
you know,
we're from that.
It's peaceful from the earth.
Why do you got to kill the Shane?
Why you got to kill the.
Why'd you have to kill the animals?
Man,
let him let him live.
I always get these guys.
Let them live.
Always,
always,
always.
They understand that if you don't kill
them,
there's going to be way more problems
for them.
If you don't,
not only do they not understand it,
but they're never going to understand
it.
No,
that's it.
I used to consider like trying to
explain that to people,
but there's,
there's,
there's really not because what is,
there's a coating that they,
it's called Polyuria is the,
um,
is the type of material.
But uh,
there's a,
there's an actual name for it.
Uh,
Adam green trees got a really,
really bad ass Toyota.
Yeah.
Well he had his built his whole back
area where the cabin is,
is all like stuff.
He's not just looks though he doesn't
have like red wheels.
He's got like real shit,
like frigerators in there and enter
fricking shower to shower off all the
mud and we actually drove to his
property and he was so mudded out that
it was impossible to get up the road
because it's pure mudslide.
And he uses winch to winch us up up his
road,
like all the way up his road with the
winch.
So.
Cool.
So it's just,
I mean the thing is like bad.
It's actually good for something.
You know,
he's been in America now for like a
month and a half,
just hunting.
He's been almost getting killed in a
tree stand last couple of days.
Hell yeah.
So he's texting to get the hell out of
that tree.
If you go to Adam Green trees,
a instagram page,
there's a video of it where he's in a
tree stand.
He's waiting like he's trying to hunt
deer and he's waiting for a deer to walk
by and he hears guns go off and then he
hears the leaves crack because bullets
are whizzing by his head and hitting the
leaves and they literally.
And there's video of it and he's like,
well,
what?
Fuck mate.
Because he's fucking as.
Yeah.
He said there was 200,
200 gunshots in six hours.
Oh yeah.
Where's he?
Kansas?
Kentucky,
Kentucky.
Not a lot of Tundras.
And have you ever been to the Midwest
during opening day?
If you drove a Tundra in Kentucky,
it would need to be bulletproof.
They would shoot at it.
Yeah.
It'd be like fricking Chevrolet man.
They have a lot of toyotas down there.
Do they?
Yeah.
They given not only that Toyota is
Toyota trucks are actually made in
America.
Believe they are.
Yeah.
Am I Tundra was made in Texas.
Yeah,
there you go.
There there's a lot of toyotas are made
in America,
you know,
uh,
the Acura Nsx,
which is a Honda that's actually made in
Ohio.
They construct,
they designed it and constructed in
Kentucky.
There you go.
Holla at your boards.
So they employ people.
They deal with people.
That used to be an issue in Detroit.
If you're in Detroit,
you were driving a non American car,
they'd shoot at it.
But now,
I mean,
so many car companies moved out of
Detroit selling cars.
They kind of gave up on that line X.
is that the coding?
Yes.
Next.
Thank you.
That shit.
You could take a line.
Exit is crazy.
That black coating,
that plastic coating that they put on
those trucks,
you can take line and cover a watermelon
with it and drop it off of a building.
Bouncing around.
Yeah.
That's.
So they take that,
that,
that matte gray,
matte black sort of cover that they look
sick.
That is a line x.
and so these line x covered trucks,
they make them and they also make them
with Kevlar windows and door panels and
bulletproof plates underneath them.
They make like a.
I feel like just a total piece of shit
and everybody wants to kill you.
You get one of those things just drive
around a lie.
Next armored vehicle.
How much of an idiot do you look like
driving that thing around?
Pretty bad ass.
Just were mirrored.
Sunglasses tell to fuck themselves.
I like the like,
I love the fricking Lynox the whole
thing.
That's like I'm watching the watermelon.
Watch this.
Look at this.
Boom.
That's a watermelon bro.
Yeah.
I was thinking look at this.
Bullying.
Well almost like a basketball.
Yeah.
So any scratches that you would
ordinarily get from like branches and
shit.
Like I bet you're the kind of travel it.
Look at this.
It is doing that to my truck.
Do you get scratched up?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
There you go.
Just like that.
You can just like pressure wash it.
You have to worry about decals coming
off.
You have to worry about anything.
You just shoot the shit down.
And it's clean.
Yeah.
One of our guides in had his truck was
lynette.
It was green.
Completely.
Yeah.
That's great.
That was Alex.
it's good stuff.
Yeah.
Alex love him.
That stuff just doesn't scratch too.
You can go so many key your car and it
just fucks up their key.
It's pretty impressive stuff.
Bunnies that we.
When you,
when you see trucks like mine here in
La,
it funnier one.
Oh,
there's a lot of them look like bad
asses.
This one looked like a killer and a
lifted truck.
You can't park in any structure.
You just true.
You can underneath
like any underground parking attendant.
You look cool.
That's important out here.
And like gridlock traffic at like 5:00
PM.
Four.
Oh five.
Yeah.
But you're above her buddy.
You got to look down on losers.
I got my lifted monster truck.
Is it a strange thing when you come from
your place?
I mean,
what is the big one and have 100,000
people or something like that.
And the entire island.
It's the biggest island.
All of Hawaiian.
Yeah.
And you know,
you go from there to here where there's
100,000
people,
you know,
go to West hills right here.
There's probably 100,000
people for every,
like three blocks.
It is weird coming here.
I spent a lot of my life in California
actually,
even though I was born and raised on the
big island and every time I get off the
plane I just so baffling that freaking
lax airport and getting on the fricking
shuttle for the rental car and then
getting a rental car and then getting on
the four.
Oh five.
And everyone's going 90.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
There's always an adjustment period of
like a half an hour.
So when I'm driving I'm like in the slow
lane,
like why this is really happening 80
miles an hour and then cost flyby going
80 miles an hour and everyone's going 80
and no one's getting stopped.
And I don't know,
it's just a shock.
Well,
you're used to place where people don't
even pass people in the highway.
Yeah.
Lived on those roads.
If someone passes people in those little
single lane roads,
people get mad,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
We get mad,
they get mad if you're going too fast,
like slow down.
Yeah.
Well the same,
the mainland.
That's,
that's,
that's whole Hawaii is Hawaii.
Like I think,
I think we were talking about this on
the,
on the last,
last time I was here,
but Hawaii is just a,
it's a different kind of place where
yeah,
you don't,
you don't pass people just because
they're going a little bit slower on
the,
on the highway and if you do,
you better make sure they're not the
wrong person.
They're gonna fuck you up.
Yeah.
You to,
you want to show respect to the people
and,
and uh,
I,
you know,
I think there's like a,
there's like this dynamic in Hawaii
where,
you know,
I mean everyone who moves there is,
that's fine.
I don't think anyone gets mad at that,
but you just don't want those people to
move to Hawaii because they love Hawaii
and then try to turn it into California,
respect their culture,
the way people act and then respect the,
the vibe that everything is more
relaxed.
But that's why it's so cool to visit.
Yeah.
Because you,
you literally feel relaxed when you get
there because everything's relaxed.
It's a different.
It's a different vibe.
People forget that though.
People move to Hawaii for that and then
they moved to.
Didn't want to turn it into California.
Does that happen?
Do you want to buy a big house on the
beach and put a big wall around it and
keep everyone out of the private beach
and had like their own little zone and
this is,
this is my zone and my stuff and my
giant house and you'd actually go on the
beach is kind of her hilarious.
Holding like a chunk of beach.
Like you don't own that bitch.
Like you decided to put a giant.
Don't try next to the ocean.
Do they have security guards in Malibu?
Yeah.
Try to keep people off of public
beaches.
They say this is a private beach,
like no,
no,
it's connected to the ocean.
Motherfucker.
Like your yard is the ocean.
Yeah.
Like my friend has kids.
He has a
beach house and my friend has kids and
the kids Surf and the kids were surfing
just,
you know,
a few hundred yards from their house and
they were in front of this guy's house.
The guy comes out of the House fucking
screaming at them saying,
get the fuck Outta here.
You're not supposed to be here.
Like,
nope.
You can't tell people that just because
you spend a lot of money on a house
that's on the beach.
It doesn't mean you own the beach.
You don't.
That's the beach.
It's the whole Earth's beach.
Like someone can come here from all
around the world and walk on that beach.
That's,
that's your yard.
You fucked up.
You bought this $15 million dollar house
that anybody could walk 30 feet from
your house.
Like that's just how it is,
dude.
Sorry.
Isn't that weird that people don't get
that they've finally gotten to super
ultra rich category that the rules don't
apply anymore?
Well,
they're just trying that.
I'm disgraced peaches,
mind they're trying to scare people off
of it,
so they've hired a lot of security
guards.
See if you can find the article.
How miserable of those people imagine
being that person who's like yelling at
kids because they're in front on the
beach.
Yeah.
That guy is living in his own personal
hell.
I don't care how rich it is.
It's just.
It's just stupid.
Like if you live on the beach,
you have to kind of accept that your
house is next to this public park.
You're essentially living in a public
park.
Mean you have his dope view.
You get to look at the ocean.
What's.
Yeah,
but what's in front of your house is
everybody's.
It just is everybody's.
You don't.
You can't own it and it's never not
going to be.
And it moves.
It goes,
and that's one of the weird things that
happened.
Apparently they did something in Santa
Barbara.
They did something to the,
to the ocean.
They did something like they put up some
sort of a barrier,
some sort of break in Santa Barbara and
it affected broad beach in a crazy way,
like it pushed the water way closer
because one of the good things about
broad beach,
these I think they call a billionaire
beach,
was that these people,
these crazy fucking houses,
they had this long stretch of sand
before the water and then the water came
way up to almost to where the houses are
now.
So it's all gone,
but now the people that utilize the
beach are literally right from these
people's houses.
So they're fucking freaking out crazy.
We've seen.
Is there any articles about.
Yeah,
so these people have hired security
guards to kick people off and then
people are getting together and these
lawsuits against these people that own
these houses.
So you can't keep us off the hatches and
I never want to be those people dark.
Can we establish that and I just,
I just want to keep those people here.
I just want to keep going.
Surfing and bowling and how the
wealthier laying claim to the cow,
to California's coast complaints have
been streaming about security guards,
uh,
hired by wealthy homeowner homeowners,
removing people from public beaches.
You can't,
those security guards,
they can't do anything.
Like if they touched you,
like be assault.
Like you can't tell me I can't walk on
the beach.
You can't,
you can't do anything.
I was trying to read through this.
The first case says that security guard
went
and got a sheriff and the sheriff told
them that they're going to get a ticket
if they didn't cut off the beach.
The sheriffs are all scared because
they'll,
all those people won the influence of
all these wealthy people.
The wealthy people influenced the
politicians.
The sheriff's want to keep their jobs.
I mean,
the whole thing is just crazy.
But the thing is now today this stuff is
getting out and it's getting out on the
Internet and it's getting out in these
stories and articles that are on the
Internet.
Homeowners have employed several tactics
to keep their beach front properties.
Private.
Recent example of a case in Malibu and
vibe involved a property owner charging
people $40 to walk on the beach and
banning surfing.
Unless the person was a resident or a
friend of a resident.
What you can't.
You can't just decide.
That's crazy.
That's like literally going up to a
state park and saying,
no one can go in here.
It's too close to my house.
Yeah,
there's nothing right about that stuff
and I don't get,
I don't,
I just hate that kind of right there.
That mentality that gives me the
gnarliest anxiety.
I just don't want to be anywhere near
those people.
I just want to get a far far away from
them and like live in the mountains in
Hawaii or.
I do
look at this.
She had been on the beach with just a
few minutes with a tall uniform security
guard approached.
He said he told Schwartz she was
trespassing on private property and
threatened her with a $1,500
fine and a court citation
if she didn't leave,
she's an employee to have the uh,
mission,
right?
She said yeah,
she's a commissioned employee.
Was asked to do some reconnaissance
falling stream of formal complaints.
At that point I pulled out the maps that
I had and said,
you know,
this is a public area.
Swartz were called,
but the guard disregarded her insistence
after telling her she needed to provide
legal proof that she had a right to be
there.
The guard left and returned 20 minutes
later with two sheriff's deputies who
slipped swiftly.
Advisor Schwartz at the beach was not
for public use.
Then I got a bit unsettled.
She remembers as brave as I like to
think I am.
I kind of started shaking a little bit
and started to get a little nervous.
Did you read it?
That was,
um,
if you go back up,
Jamie,
it'll say,
whose house that was?
I think it was David Geffen's daily that
happened also near his house.
Same.
Deliberately restricted public access.
That same thing happen with Mark
Zuckerberg on quiet.
It's 2013.
The Guardian reported how entertainment
mogul David Geffen had deliberately
restricted,
deliberately restricted public access to
the beach near his home and carbon
beach.
Yeah,
that's another really.
You can't do do
that.
Yeah.
Mark Zuckerberg did that.
Alkali real.
Yeah,
he bought up this beautiful property on
the north coast of Clive's.
Incredible,
beautiful place with incredible waves
and not that many people live there and
he bought this insane like thousands of
acres right there when the most
beautiful places on earth and then try
to keep everybody out and like
completely blocked all the access and
all the Hawaiians,
all the local people got extremely angry
with him and if he just would have been.
I mean he.
He's going to be a resident,
right?
You wouldn't think this little island on
coal eyes.
People been living there.
You can't just like storm in there by
all the property up and block everyone
out.
How you got to deliver and I don't know,
but is it like alumni sized or smaller?
Malott more than.
Yeah,
a lot more.
probably be 40,000
or something like that.
Maybe 30,000,
but you know,
the people on choir really territorial
and protective of where they live and
they live in a really beautiful place
and a lot of people who aren't from
there.
We have lots of money,
want to live there,
people,
people inquire hypersensitive to that
already.
So you got like Mark Zuckerberg,
you know,
probably worth $80,000,000,000
or something.
Come in there and buy up all the land
and try and block everyone.
It's not a good move.
While he's probably a terrible move,
but he's probably super insulated to
people.
Right?
I mean everywhere that guy goes,
he brings security guards with them or
you'd have to.
And he's probably like,
he probably has almost no interaction
with regular people you would think.
So these young man so young,
he's like 34 some shit.
How old is he,
Jamie?
What's your worth?
$80.
Billion.
Imagine being in your thirties and worth
$80,000,000,000.
Still working.
How about that?
That's cool though.
I love that about these guys.
Like um,
I wouldn't do it,
but like Elon Musk and,
and,
and Zuckerberg,
it's,
it's cool.
Those guys believe so much that they can
actually make a difference,
that they're still,
that's the only reason that's keeping
them where it's not the money.
He paid $100,
million dollars to purchase 700 acres of
land.
Wow.
It's 34,
34.
That's crazy.
Straight up bowling ball and out.
Woo As balling.
There's a big difference in him and
Nealon Musto.
He's got a weird reputation of fucking
over the people that he'd made made
facebook with.
I don't know if that's correct or not,
but that movie,
man,
I sue the fuck out of those people made
that movie.
If that's not true,
right in the movie,
they kind of set it up like he stole the
idea.
Well,
he had to settle.
He settled out of court.
Paid a lot of millions to like the
winklevoss brothers I think to,
to uh,
because they said it was their idea.
Yeah.
They made him look like a Dick in that
movie though.
They shared it.
It's kind of heavy that that movie
actually got made.
You would think that they would have got
paid off to not make it.
Well,
it's weird to make a movie about a
person,
even if they got accurate reports from
other people.
It's so weird to make a movie about a
person who's still alive right now and
put words in his mouth.
Has a lot of it is speculation too,
no matter what.
For sure.
Yeah.
Off Light.
It says that the settlement was $20,
million in cash and $45 million in
facebook stock price.
They're worth billions.
Yeah,
he got off light.
Yeah.
If he did dick them over.
But who knows if they're telling the
truth version,
there's always.
There's always two sides to every story,
but a movie about you.
Like if somebody made a movie about you
and you know,
had you on the beach saying some shit
you never really said like,
Hey,
I didn't say those words.
You can't have me say those words with
an actor's inflection and his decisions
to make whatever creative he makes with
the way he talks.
And Ninety nine percent of the people
watching that movie aren't having this
conversation with people.
They just automatically think that
Zuckerberg,
that's what happened.
Dick,
he's a dick.
He did that.
He did those.
That's the perception.
It's like if you,
uh,
if like Jamie was like,
hey,
you know what,
I just got fired by Joe.
Fuck that guy.
You know what?
Joe's Joe.
Joe Tried to touch me this one day when
I was shooting the techno target target.
He tried to touch me.
Everyone had maybe believe Jamie,
especially if he was like a really
pretty girl.
Yeah.
Jamie can be a pretty girl if he shaves
hair.
It goes.
I tried to stop it being God damn ad
blocker.
He did try to stop it being made
according to this.
Yeah.
Shin.
You would though would need to stop the
movie,
the social network for being made.
I was from those leaks on emails that
came out in that hacking thing.
Oh,
of course he did,
but I think he has a right to it
honestly.
Yeah.
Here's the thing,
pretty heavy that someone can make a
movie about you without your consent and
put words in your mouth.
That would be the thing.
It'd be one thing if you were convicted
in a court of law for that stuff,
but if,
if this is just like,
yeah,
I swear this happened.
See,
here's the thing though,
it's one thing if there's a documentary
and the documentary,
they're showing footage where Zuckerberg
is doing certain things and saying
certain things.
It's a total different situation.
If you decide to put words in that guy's
mouth and you have fucking Justin
timberlake plan in a movie.
Who Played Him in the movie?
I think it was justin timberlake.
Was it Justin Trudeau?
Yeah,
he's in it.
Jesse Eisenberg.
So you have a famous actor.
The famous actor plays you in a movie
and makes you out to be a con.
That sucks.
It's his choice.
He sucks and then the director is like,
make it a little more country.
Can you do a little more contained?
Like,
okay,
I'll go a little more of a dick.
I'll be a little more removed here.
We'll try a little more removed.
This next take.
Yeah.
It's like you can't do that.
You should.
You should be able to sue the fuck out
of those people because at the end of
the day,
it's one thing to tell a story.
Hey,
I worked with Zuckerberg.
That guy was a dick.
He stole my ideas.
It's another thing to have someone play
him in a movie and make up a bunch of
words that he didn't really say or you
don't know.
He really said,
Oh,
you don't have any proof that.
He really said that's a fucking snitch
range.
Like I've always felt that way about
historical movies.
Like they make a movie about Abraham
Lincoln.
Like someone was saying,
how the fuck did they do a movie?
Abraham Lincoln,
vampire killer,
you know?
See,
that's too heavy.
It was really ridiculous.
Abraham Lincoln was killer.
Was one of the dumbest movies ever take
to make it east killing vampires.
I think with an ax,
think he killed them with an ax.
It was really stupid,
but I was saying,
yeah,
it's dumb,
but is it any dumber than any other
Abraham Lincoln movie?
You have a bunch of movies about Abraham
Lincoln where he's just hanging out with
his kids and talk.
You don't know what the fuck.
He said,
you don't know what kind of interaction
he actually had with his wife.
You weren't there.
How do you.
How do you pitch that movie to a studio?
You know what,
guys?
I got this concept,
I got this concept.
That's when you know you've got way too
much money is when you're making movies
about Abraham Lincoln and being a
vampire killer.
Yeah.
Pull up.
Pull up the trailer for Abraham Lincoln,
vampire slayer.
I was trying to remember if I remember
correctly though.
This came at a time to the guy that
wrote the book that this movie was made
from wrote pride and pride,
pride and prejudice and zombies were.
He rewrote pro,
excuse me,
pride and browse,
but added a zombie like plot throughout
it,
so we had to say he mashed up the story.
It was successful.
So he did it again with like an amber,
Abraham Lincoln,
a biography,
but added vampires to it.
Is there demand and it went and the
demand that is there enough people on
earth that wants to watch shit movies?
Seriously.
I don't know,
man.
Time is precious.
I want to watch something really good.
Not really bad.
I don't know,
man.
There's nobody walking into that movie
like,
this is going to be sick.
You might be operating on a higher
frequency than most.
There's a lot of people out there that
just want to be entertained but
stupidity.
He'll give me.
Give me full screen on this stupid piece
of shit.
I watched this thing high as a kite to
you watch this movie.
Oh yeah.
Were you.
Were you in that shack on the big island
when you watch this?
Tim Burton?
Yeah.
This,
this trailer actually looks pretty
fucking cool.
See watching him tell Liam Neeson.
Look,
it's fucking up all these vampires.
Wow.
Abraham Lincoln,
vampire hunter.
He chopped down that tree with one swing
duty.
So bad ass.
Very high percentage of people watching
that movie.
Where high.
Yeah.
Well see,
I think I see things that are not good
for my job.
See,
I will.
Yeah.
I will go.
I will watch movies and television
shows.
I will watch things hoping.
Hoping it's sucked bad enough to become
a part of my.
He didn't have to hope very hard to do.
That.
Doesn't make it in there.
I watched this as where the whole thing.
I was like,
fuck.
It looks like jokes like a,
like a,
like a joke factory does.
It looks like it should be a joke
factory.
It's not.
Well,
maybe someone better than me came out
like two months before the.
The Lincoln movie with Daniel Day Lewis,
like rushed it out to.
That guy is amazing.
By the way,
Daniel Day Lewis.
Holy Moly.
But that was another movie that bothered
me.
I saw the Daniel Day.
Lewis Lincoln movie was kind of dull to
slow.
Yeah,
but it bothered me that we don't really
know what the fuck this guy said.
It's one thing like there will be blood,
which was fucking amazing.
Yeah,
but those are fake people.
Man.
He looked good as Lincoln.
Crazy.
How good they made them out.
Remember gangs in New York when he was
bob the butcher bill.
Billy butcher.
Yeah.
He's phenomenal.
He's great in everything.
So good man.
He's just one of those guys.
It just becomes completely.
There's one.
There's a few people that a lot of
people that are actors that are just
Weirdos.
They're just these really strange people
that desperately want attention.
They figured out a way to use their
mental illness to,
to navigate the waters of Hollywood.
In some strange way where their virtue
signaling and and,
and,
and behaving exactly the way Hollywood
wants them to behave to get themselves
into these positions of fame,
and then they become movie stars and
they say a bunch of nonsense and these,
you hear them interviewed you,
like you're not even a person.
Like,
this is not a person.
It's not a person talking.
There's no sincerity,
there's no reality to it.
You just painfully aware of every word
you're saying and how people going to
perceive it.
And you just know there's no Ouzo your
guards never down.
They're just Weirdos.
And then there's people like Daniel Day
Lewis who is just this savage.
You just figures out how to become these
real deal.
Yeah.
I mean he fucking stays in character.
That was great.
Last the Mohicans.
He's so good.
He's fucking great and everything.
You retired,
you know,
he does now.
Huh?
Make shoes.
Are you serious?
Yeah,
he is a cobbler.
He makes shoes by hand.
That's what he does.
Wow.
Yeah.
He's a legend.
I back,
dude,
are you kidding me?
And he was so good.
Hilda the butcher.
Yeah,
I would fly to wherever the fuck he is.
You get a shoe made by him.
Should do it.
I should.
I wonder if you make shoes for people
probably just makes shoes for his
friends would like,
does he have a company?
Like I know he makes shoes,
but like what does he do at these God
damn shoes?
What's his lifestyle like?
You know what I mean?
After all that like,
you know,
I was saying like all those crazy
moments I got human potential like you
know,
his human potential of his,
like acting craft like during like last
Mohicans and,
and uh,
gangs in New York and stuff like going
from that like extreme,
those extreme highs and yeah,
know performance levels to making shoes.
That's crazy.
Usually people go up not,
not,
you know,
up in intensity,
not down intensity.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
The intensity aspect of it is really
interesting.
But I think for him,
like he's,
he's such an artist that I don't think
he cares whether or not people are
looking at his art.
I think he cares about the process of
creating.
So I think the same to him.
Yeah,
I think the process,
well maybe even more pure because of the
fact that it doesn't have any adulation.
There's no.
There's no spotlight on it.
There's no publicity team.
There's no stupid interviews he asked to
do.
You know what I mean?
I'm like,
yeah,
that stuff must be maddening for him to
sit down with someone from fucking e
entertainment television.
So mad.
You got another dope movie coming out.
Tell us about.
It sounds like you need a Daniel Day
Lewis on the podcast here.
He'd
be freaking amazing,
but maybe he would have.
Cool.
That'd be to talk about shoes.
You probably be cycling on that.
Maybe I will talk to that guy for three
hours just about shoes.
If he was into.
Just tell me about your stitching
process.
Like what do you choose your leather?
I don't think,
from what I just read,
I don't think that he does it.
It says that he took time off from
making movies to study under this very
well known shoemaker for 10 months
specifically and only did thou.
Then he came back though.
He made a movie like last year called
the phantom thread,
which were,
he was a designer,
a fashion designer,
and then he learned to,
uh,
in order to do that he reverse
engineered a Valencia,
Aka dress and to just to learn how to
become a fashion Jaga dressed.
You know what,
that we,
we pulled up at the blend stock as a
company.
It's that they make that shirt we made,
we put up a few weeks ago,
he doubles shirt thing.
So it's a high end,
very high end stuff.
Um,
so yeah,
and then put it back together again so
he could understand the process of doing
it.
That was like his for us,
how he became it,
got into character for the,
for that movie.
So I don't know if he's retired all the
way.
It doesn't seem like he makes a believer
he retired and when he made that movie
last year though,
since 2017 for a while,
he likes six.
There's only one way to find out.
He did retire.
It took some time off as Daniel.
If you're out there anytime to just
Holler at me.
I don't know.
I know you don't have a dog,
but I know you don't have a twitter,
but I got people.
You got people.
He was amazing in the movie.
The boxer two,
in my opinion,
he did.
He played the most believable
professional boxer in a film because a
lot of films like even like the movie
with Marky mark where he played,
um,
micky ward.
It was like Mark Walberg knows how to
punch.
He knows how to throw punches,
but there's a difference between
throwing punches in a movie and a guy
throwing punches in a fight.
And if you look at the way Daniel Day
Lewis is performing in that boxing
movie,
he looks like a guy who's throwing
punches in a fight.
It's way more realistic.
Any boxing movie I've ever seen.
And he boxed for a full year before we
did that movie.
You mean just lived in a boxing gym.
He trained all the time,
sparred,
hit the pads.
He got real coaching from.
He played a guy who is an Ira guy who
got out of jail and then got back into
boxing and then there's a bunch of
terrorists,
shit involved in the film's very good
movie,
but see if you can find footage of him
from that movie.
So when,
when you see boxing movies,
guys are throwing punches like they know
they're not going to get hit back.
Like this is a certain thing about
boxing.
Like if you watch a guy actually
fighting,
there's a tension,
there's a tension to worry about her
getting hit back and you see a movie
about a boxer goes like,
hey man,
it's just too much.
The myths are down,
their chins out.
It's not just that.
It's like the way they're moving.
There's no anticipation.
There's no offense.
Right?
Even when they're getting hit,
it's bullshit.
It's
like you can tell it makes it drives me
crazy to watch him in here.
I mean,
this guy,
he,
he studied and trained,
I forget who was training,
um,
but it was like legit professional
boxers see crazy.
That commitment that these guys do to
take their acting to the next level
because it's like there's not that many
people who have noticed that he fights
more like a real fighter.
You know what I'm saying?
No,
there's not.
But even like see like other ways
throwing these punches like this is the
way a real boxer throws punches.
Like they're not wide.
Everything's real tight.
Pretty fucking impressive.
But I mean I would expect nothing else
from this guy.
Yeah,
he's legit.
He's a madman.
Yeah.
Legit.
But it'd be a real Weirdo to talk to.
Yeah,
I know.
It's only one way to find out.
Yeah.
You want me to get them on?
When are we going hunting?
I Dunno.
I think June you want to do may or June.
Let's try to plan something.
Yeah,
for sure.
The Nih does the next one.
You should come with us to Dudley's
place in Oklahoma and in March we're
going to go pig hunting.
That'd be fun.
It's infested march
actually.
The size of that gigantic pig that he
shot down there.
Yeah,
I did monster 450 pound pig.
Shit.
It's like a tank,
so it's as big as this table,
these huge big pork chops.
It's the three of us stack together form
the form.
It's so mark shake.
Yeah.
We're going to do it in March and it
sounds like fun.
Yeah.
He has a giant place that he leases in
Oklahoma and it's all.
It's all just just beautiful,
wild,
open country.
Oklahoma's very underrated.
You ever been to Oklahoma?
I've never been to the Midwest.
Ohio tomorrow.
Oh,
you're going white tail hunt the first
time ever.
Is that the Midwest?
Yes.
See,
I've never even know where the Midwest
is.
Hawaii.
Yeah.
Know Ohio's shit.
I'm a Midwest Virgin,
so I'm going back to Ohio.
That's actually where my mom is from,
so.
Oh,
that's cool.
What part of a why or what part of Ohio
rather?
I think the southern part.
I'm going,
I'm going to white tail hunting right
now.
I've got to go.
And what part of Mrs?
Right in the middle.
So that's Portsmith Kentucky area.
Maybe you're Cincinnati.
I'm is my favorite spot.
I'm hoping it's not too cold.
Columbus,
the Shit I'm a big fan of Cleveland to,
but God Damn Columbus is a shit.
Columbus is awesome.
I'm excited to see it.
Just for whatever font,
what I.
I'm guessing it's foreign lands flat,
is that right?
Not Flat.
That's the misinterpretations.
It's flatter than most areas for sure,
but like especially down from Columbus
down to the South area where the rivers
go,
there's a spa,
there's Indian mounds and there's all
sorts of a glacier cut out spaces.
Yeah,
the hocking hills is a very cool spot
and there's also this old man's cave is
a really cool spot to.
It's like a traditional.
I think Columbus is one of the most
underrated cities in the country.
Yeah.
People don't think about it as it's like
the people are fucking cool.
It's a really good place to stand up for
stand up comedy.
So one of the best places in the world.
It's just fucking phenomenal.
They're smart,
but they're also like midwest type
people,
but they uh,
but they,
they're not stuck up.
Right.
You know,
it's like,
it's like a,
almost like Chicago.
It's like a lot like Chicago.
I think.
Well,
I'm not going to see it.
I'm just gonna.
Go straight to my tree stand.
Yeah.
Treestand hung.
Have you ever done it before?
I've done a little bit of trees down
hunting,
but it's a mind fuck.
I'm really bad at.
I'm.
I'm,
I'm impatient.
I like to be stocking.
I like to be on the move.
I like to be finding deer.
I like to be,
you know,
I like that being.
I like to hunt.
I want to be the hunter and so for me,
like sitting in a tree for four days
straight,
it will be interesting to see if I have
what it takes.
It's weird too because oddly aware that
if you fail,
you're fucked.
Like you have to wear a harness and all
that jazz.
Like I did it with Dudley the first time
I ever treat.
I've hunted deer before on the ground in
a ground blind,
but the first time ever did it in a tree
stand was at Dudley's place.
That's where you gotta go.
Dudley.
Dudley has the craziest spot.
I'm going to hit up.
Dudley then Doug,
he's got like 600 acres all bowhunting.
He lives in,
he lives in.
He literally lives in White Tail
Paradigm.
Wow.
He lives in Iowa right in one of the
best places in the world.
For him to send me a text,
send him a text.
Have you down.
You got to check it for an Iowa tag
though.
It's going to be cold this week.
Cool as fuck.
Son.
Prepare for girl.
Hi.
Era Hawaiian.
Yeah.
Does under armour have some good white
tail close?
They do,
yeah.
They sent.
They sent me some really,
really warm clothes for hunting.
You might want to get one of those
thermal fucking things.
Have you seen the heated sleeping bags?
Oh yeah.
Those are dope.
Dude.
You could wear one of those up there.
I could.
Yeah.
They have those things.
What are they called in inferno suits or
something like that.
What are those things called?
See,
the thing is I like.
I like hunting and cold weather.
I love it.
Super cold weather.
Even if I can in my stocking around,
I can walk around.
You can move.
It's not that cold,
but if you.
The whole point of sitting in a tree
stand,
you have to try and sit completely 100
percent still and move as little as
possible and you're freezing your dick
off.
You don't have to.
It doesn't even have to be that cold for
you to freeze.
Right?
If you're trying not to move,
yeah,
it can be in the fifties and you'd be
freezing your balls off.
Right?
Because you're not moving so your body's
not generating heat.
But I've hunted when it's like,
you know,
eight degrees or 10 degrees in eastern
Colorado and I was okay because I could
move.
You know that you're taking layers off
if you're going up hills.
Right?
Like that is one of the things that's
really interesting to me about hunting
and cold weather is the whole layering
system is that you have to really be
aware of when you're sweating.
So the whole key is to get yourself to
the point where you're never sweating so
as your mood,
because if you're sweating and then you
have to cool off and then you have to
sweat,
it kills herself up.
Your clothes are wet from
sweat,
you're fucked.
Yeah,
you know,
that's one of the beautiful things about
wool is that will allow you to retain
your body heat,
even if it's wet,
you know,
he doesn't,
doesn't really fuck with you the same
way that a lot of synthetics and
particularly cotton cotton's the worse.
Yeah.
Synthetics are good because they,
it,
they,
they'll,
they'll dry quickly.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Have you ever seen that rewarming drill
that John Barklow from Sitka did where
he jumps in a river with wet clothes and
chose how to heat your body back up now.
But I just did a hunt with a um,
I just had a hunt with John Hart from
Sitka.
Yeah.
He's a great guy.
He was a lot of fun hunting with and we
talked about survival stuff a bit like,
you know,
stuff like that.
Like what do you do if you fall in a
river and it's cold.
That guy who attend me is like one of
the,
I mean because he owns the company.
He's one of the best representations of
what you would want from a guy who owns
a big company,
who was a ceo of a big company that's
involved in hunting.
Super Smart,
really articulate conservation minded,
very ethical,
just solid,
super solid.
I was with him in Utah.
Yeah.
Great Guy.
Awesome company too.
I know you're a good stuff.
Yeah.
There's,
there's,
you know,
I mean,
there's a lot of good stuff out there,
but I just,
uh,
yeah.
I'm,
I'm hoping I stay warm on this,
on his hunt in BC.
Where were you guys were in Hawaii.
Oh,
that's right.
That's right.
I was thinking you were in that Moose
hunt that they just come back from
China.
We're hunting in Hawaii.
So you were in that crazy ranch.
That's somewhere on the big island.
The people never hunt,
right?
Um,
some big area.
Yeah,
we were,
we were hunting on the big island.
Um,
we're hunting pigs.
It,
I was,
I was hunting in an area that was like,
um,
I explain it.
We're,
yeah,
we're,
we're hunting these big bars on the big
island.
And uh,
it was a lot of fun.
It was great.
But he's a,
he's,
he's a really good dude.
Yeah.
Did they have like numbers that they
have to keep the pigs down to,
do they have like a point where the pigs
reach?
Because for people who don't know,
it really does have several litters a
year and if they're not because there's
no predators on Hawaii.
So if the pigs aren't kept in check by
people,
they'll get completely out of hand.
So do they have wildlife biologists who
manage the numbers and try to decide
like what to do?
They just try and kill as many as again.
So they just have people hunt
constantly.
Yeah.
And is it not a problem because so many
people hunt there?
I mean it just sorta depends who you
ask.
It's,
it's,
it's crazy because like with the pigs,
the pigs can thrive and really thick
areas.
So there is very difficult to do like a
to figure out how many pigs there are.
Like if you try and count the number of
deer on Maui,
people count them.
My friend Jake does it,
he'll fly in the grid and they'll get a
pretty darn accurate reading of how many
deer on the island,
but try and figure out how many pigs on
the big island.
It's impossible.
They live in the jungle,
right?
Because they're all in underbrush.
They.
Yeah.
But the deer,
they come out in the open,
you know,
and you chased him with a,
with a helicopter and you can see them.
They're all running pigs.
Don't do that.
Just go right into the thick.
So basically there's infinite numbers of
pigs on the big island.
So do they also have sheep?
We have,
we have moved on sheet.
We have like a,
like a hybrid sheep.
We have um,
we got goats and,
and those you can,
you can get numbers of and you can knock
them down really quick if you're trying
to eradicate them.
Pigs.
It's really difficult.
How did the move launch?
Cheap taste move on.
Cheaper.
Amazing.
Yeah,
that's what I've heard.
They're really fantastic.
They're great to hunt.
Did you see that controversy that
happened pretty recently where a woman
shot a shot,
a wild sheep?
I did one year up goat Europe in Europe
and people were upset at her and all
these Ricky Gervais',
of course he has to jump in.
That's his favorite thing.
Glenn Greenwald,
all these people jumped in.
What would they don't understand is
these wild goats are invasive species.
They have no natural predators and they.
They hunt them to preserve the wildlife.
That's indicative,
that's native to the area.
Whether it's the plant life,
animal life,
I mean these,
these goats,
if their populations are left unchecked,
they hunt them for a very specific
reason,
like really.
Have you talked to some wildlife
biologists?
They should be eradicated because there
are.
A lot of them were left on islands.
People don't realize this by whalers
the.
They left them on these islands because
this was an island off of a,
I believe it was off of Ireland or
Scotland.
See if you can find that story.
Scotland,
a lot of them are left there by by
travelers so that they would have food
there when they came back,
so they would drop these things off on
these certain islands and in fact there
was a real area,
a real problem where they drop them off,
so this was the woman and people got all
over this lady for shooting this wild
goat,
which is really kind of crazy because
they eat them,
they're delicious.
They either have his food,
they're invasive.
I mean there's so many things going in
in toe pointing towards the direction
that this was actually a smart
conservation thing to do,
but I guess maybe it was because of the
way she talked about it.
No,
because she said it was a really fun
hunt or something like that,
but like I get it,
it's like a,
it's like a beautiful creature and it
would have still been alive if she
wasn't there.
So that perspective of people just like,
you know why you got to kill it?
It's,
it's,
it's a,
it's a wild animal.
Living on an island,
you can't just let them live.
It's a natural perspective.
It's as simple as that normal human
nature to think that,
but you know all the people who think
that if you dig a little deeper,
there's a lot more information there
with those.
You just can't let those go to get out
of hand.
There was hardy as hell.
They don't die,
but that's the problem with Greg.
I'm Ricky Gervais' or Glenn Greenwald,
someone like that,
that has a giant platform that loves
animals and I appreciate that and that
instantly post something like this,
very inflammatory without looking into
it deeper.
They use their platform and they think
to expose something they think is
horrific,
but they don't understand what's going
on behind the scenes of this.
There's a thing called Judas goats,
and what they do is they'll take a goat
and they'll noodle that goat and put a
gps tag on it and send it out because
goats always flock together in this goat
will go near the other goats and then
they fly over with helicopters and gun
these goats down and this is just to
keep goat populations in check so they
kill every goal,
but the Judas Goat and then the Judas
go,
we'll find other goats and then they fly
over again and gone all the goats down
and this is done by wildlife biologist,
right by my house.
They do this just because those goats
eat everything.
I have a friend who lives in Topanga and
they bought goats to clean their
property.
They thought,
oh,
this would be a good idea.
We'll bring these goats in and they'll
eat all the weeds and they'll know they
eat everything.
Everything.
Every last thing they keep going and
still they'll decimate local wildlife
like whatever their their habitat is.
They'll devastate all these local
plants.
I mean things that are supposed to be
there that have been there forever.
When these invasive species get there,
they have a really hard time maintaining
and then it gets to a point where they
have to do something about it.
Well,
this,
this woman paid to do that so that money
goes towards conservation.
She gets to eat the meat,
you know,
she has this enjoyable experience
hunting these things in the mountains,
but people don't want to look at that.
They just want to look at it.
It shouldn't die,
and it's really particularly crazy when
it's a guy like Ricky Gervais' who eats
meat.
Yeah,
so like the whole thing is just.
It's so strange.
It's just so strange that people refuse
to look deeper into these things and
they immediately have these knee jerk
reactions where they want to complain
about it and do so publicly in a way
that gets all these people to attack
this woman.
Well,
the photo of that dead animal,
that's what.
That's what initiates that,
that response,
emotional response.
That gets smiling and then they'll go to
the fridge and grab some steak and cook
it and think nothing of it.
Nothing at all of that meat is.
They don't.
They don't see the parallel there,
they just think that it's completely
different than weird that someone wants
to go hunt them.
Yeah,
it's fucked up in this weird accepted,
hypocritical way.
I mean it's,
it's oddly accepted,
but we all have freezers full of the
best meat there is and eat it every
night and it's amazing.
I'm never going to stop.
We do.
Yeah.
We that hunt.
We do that.
We actually have that connection with
that meat.
We killed it.
We skinned it,
we got the meat,
we de-bone it.
We packed it out.
We packaged it and put it in our
freezers ourselves.
But this is the first step.
Second.
Awesome.
It's the first ever seen someone get
attacked at something that's immediate
animal because a,
I've seen people,
maybe they don't know what's a meat
animal,
but I've seen people get attacked for
obviously for anything like that it's
appliance
and yeah,
the Predator one is the biggest one I'll
give you.
Kill something that's a predator.
People for whatever weird reason,
freak out more than anything.
Well,
and if there's any,
if there's like a,
like a,
like a general idea that they're
endangered.
Right.
You know what I mean?
Like everybody thinks that lions are
endangered or elephants are endangered
or even bear bears are embarrassed or
danger.
Yeah.
So,
um,
yeah,
there's a lot of misconceptions out
there for sure.
But I don't really eat lions or
elephants or.
And like that idea.
And there's millions of deer.
Millions.
Yeah.
Literally.
I mean where we hunt in Lanai has 3000
people more.
They estimate somewhere over 20,000
deer and they don't even know.
I mean it's just an Nana's.
I'm on a text thread with,
with Benny O'Brian and Rennie and,
and I'll and all you guys.
And there was a stat that they were
saying yesterday,
I don't know if you're on that text and
they were saying that like in one of the
Midwest states,
I don't know which one it was.
Do you remember in one of the Midwest
states,
like 850,000
deer die during gun season and half of
them like 400,000
deer die in the first two days because.
Because we were talking about Adam being
in the tree.
That's crazy.
In one state alone,
850,000
deer die during gun season.
So you think of how many deer that is.
Imagine if no one hunted for like three
years.
What was that stat?
How many deer there would be the number
of car accidents nationwide with dear?
I think it's a million and a half.
I mean,
but the people who get angry at the
photos don't think of what it would be
like if you just stopped hunting.
Yeah.
No.
How many goats Arab he imagined,
dear nature would sort itself out.
It wouldn't.
Well,
it would eventually be.
You'd have to bring in wolves.
If you're comfortable with wolves,
eat and your kids.
I mean that's what it is.
Yours and all that big bad wolf shit
from when we're little kids like little
pig,
little pig.
Let me in.
That's because wolves were everywhere
and they were bad.
It was dangerous.
Like you would go through people's kids.
That really did happen.
Yeah.
We just.
We've got so far away from that.
We forgot about it as a possibility,
so now we think of them as dogs that are
living their natural,
that dogs just living his best life out
in the woods.
How other one,
they howl,
they're trying,
they're trying to figure out how to eat
you.
They want to get through your house,
which they're trying to figure out how
to eat your kids and if you reintroduce
them into yellow stone,
they're never going to leave
yellowstone.
You're going to stay there.
They're going to stay right in this
little pocket of where they like to
live.
They're never going to reproduce into
like thousands.
Yeah,
there are those people think,
but really they're going to just start
roaming and.
Yeah,
and recreating thousands,
thousands and thousands of walls that
are all going to go into neighborhoods
eventually when that's what's happening.
That's what's happening in Montana.
That's what's happening in Idaho.
Yeah.
I mean,
these are all reintroduced wolves that
are mean and they also go on the surplus
kills or they'll kill like 15 elk and
just leave them there and they just go
nutty.
Yeah,
that's what they do.
My friend lives in Montana and he was
telling me that the wolf population is
so out of hand that the,
that the elk population has been
decimated.
It was,
it's down by like 80 percent or some
crazy stat.
Crazy though.
Yeah.
They weren't there in 1994.
I mean that's when they reintroduced
them right.
In the nineties.
So Yah,
I mean there's,
there's,
I mean now that I mean now that human
population is,
is so established and a lot of these
areas and you can't just reintroduce
wolves with no plan to keep,
keep a lid on it.
Well,
there is a plan,
but the problem with the plan is the
established numbers that they needed to
achieve in before they start managing
the population than there was immediate
lawsuits by animal rights activists who
don't want them to ever hunt wolves.
Right.
So in Montana they've opened up seasons.
They've opened up seasons in Idaho,
they've opened up seasons for wolves and
they would like to do the same for
grizzly bears and all of these areas,
and there's a lot of pushback on that
too,
but it's the same sort of thing,
the established numbers that they needed
to achieve in order to make it a
sustainable population they've been
reached and then the wildlife
biologists,
the ones are objective about are saying,
hey,
we need to keep these populations in
check in order to keep the deer
populations healthy and the Moose
populations healthy because these bears
and these wolves,
they're just destroying these calves and
they just run around and the populations
of these animals go way down.
Now there's also an argument and a
really good one that you need predators,
and this good argument is you don't ever
want to be recreated in Montana,
right?
Where there's just these deer and these
elk.
You want a certain natural balance,
and so there's an argument that there
should be a certain amount of wolves,
and I agree with that argument.
I agree too,
but the balance can be really difficult
to maintain.
Yeah,
that's.
That's my point is like if there's too
many elk and you want to control that
number,
say there's $100,000,
but there should only be $50,000.
That's,
that's the perfect number.
It's actually pretty easy to go from
100,000
and 50,000
to trial.
That elk herd back pretty easy through
through management and through hunting.
Same with deer.
You can pull that number back pretty
quick.
Wolves are fricking hard to kill,
Dude.
Yeah.
You had to kill a wolf and you had a
gun.
Fricking hard real.
If you had to kill a deer and you had a
gun,
not that hard.
You can find deer.
Finding a wolf is freaking hard,
dude.
So once those.
What my point is is once those wolf
numbers get out of hand,
trying to manage that population,
the wolf population is very,
very difficult.
We'll places that are used to dealing
with them.
They know what the fuck to do.
Like Alaska he had to them and
everything and trap them.
They fly around and planes and shoot
them out of the,
out of the air with helicopters.
I mean they eradicate them.
And then that Sarah Palin,
I don't think she's doing that anymore,
but there's a lot of people up there
that do do that and you can buy wolf
skin rugs that they,
they,
they sell those skins and turn them into
rugs and do all sorts of different
things with the pelts.
Got To do something.
Yeah,
they do something with it.
So it's.
But they do that because they have a
vested interest in keeping the
population of their game animals alive
for a couple reasons.
And there's criticism about that too,
that they may be killed too many wolves
because they don't.
They want you to be able to go there.
And a lot of their tourism dollars comes
from people that fly in to hunt.
Moose are flying to hunt deer and they
want to make sure they keep certain
populations of them there.
So it's,
it's all,
there's a real problem when you get
emotions and you have those emotions
tied into this idea of wildlife biology
and what an animal is,
and keeping healthy numbers of these
animals in a certain area that's a real,
becomes a real issue,
you know?
And that's why when this goat thing
happens and everybody freaks out over,
it's like you should probably educate
yourself as to what you're talking about
before you start complaining because he
just throwing gasoline on this fire and
you don't necessarily understand all the
circumstances involved.
Let's go there.
Not only to because it,
because they live where I live and they
on,
they love shorelines and they love like
ridges and berms and stuff like that.
And they're,
they're,
they create so much erosion because they
love those edges on,
on cliffs and stuff.
And so they,
they ran all the berms that original.
They,
they ruin all the cliffs and then
there's all this runoff and erosion and
they,
I mean they completely decimate all the
grass,
all the weeds,
all the way down.
They don't,
they don't just trim things,
they're not,
they're not selective eaters.
They'll just chow down all the way to
the,
to the roots and then eat the roots.
Also,
there's nothing holding that dirt in
place.
So when it rains,
just everything spills downhill because
of the goats.
They really.
I see,
I see it.
And with deer,
you can see some,
some impact that they have for sure as
you let those numbers get out of hand,
they have the same effect,
but goats go through radical.
They,
the populations explode and,
and if,
if someone's not managing them,
that you can see the impact that they
have on the land
and that'll have an impact on all the
native species to all the ground nesting
birds,
all the animals that use that,
those,
the grass and those different things for
cover and for life.
Yeah.
It's a.
and what they,
the things that they feed off of all
this stuff gets eaten by the goats,
you know?
Yeah.
If there's a large population of goat
somewhere,
you'll know it.
Yeah.
That was like almost nothing left.
Appreciate these people like Glenn
Greenwald.
I appreciate the sentiment behind it.
Uh,
really do.
I just wish they would look into it a
little bit deeper and you know,
this woman's not bad person.
She's just,
that's how she gets her meat,
you know?
Yup.
Like I said,
especially a guy like ricky who I've
met,
I've,
I've actually talked about hunting with
him on a radio show before on the open
anthony show.
I had explained to him that I'm a
hunter.
I hunt animals and I eat them because he
was talking about hunters and I and he
was actually very friendly with me and
we were cool about it.
We had a good.
He's like,
as long as you eat it,
that's what you're doing it for.
I'm like,
that's exactly what I do at four.
But he eats me too.
Which is so the whole.
It's weird.
It's the,
the,
the fact that people think like that
they are morally disconnected from the
act of killing an animal just because
they use a credit card to buy is so
hilarious.
But you hired a supermarket Hitman,
that's what you did.
Supermarket Hitman took a prisoner and a
prisoner,
you know,
cow and fucking put a bolt through.
It said.
And you feel.
You feel completely detached from it.
Yup.
No Karma.
Well,
and when someone needs a hamburger,
they think nothing of eating a quarter
of it or half a mil.
I'm really full.
He can just take that away from me.
Yeah.
You'd never do that with your elk do?
No,
no,
I eat it all it all.
Yeah.
I'm making sure that if I cook it,
I Cook enough so that me and my family
eat it and whatever's leftover,
uh,
no.
I'll eat in the morning or eat the next
day for lunch.
Huge difference is you have so much
respect for that meet and for that
animal because all the effort it took
and you watch that thing live in the
wild.
You have a completely different
perspective of that meat then you do.
If you just,
you know,
order a hamburger at that restaurant,
you know?
Yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
But that,
again,
that's one of those,
I mean,
you and I have developed this
perspective from years of,
of hunting and being around people hunt
and we understand it for the average
person that's never going to encounter
that in their entire life.
Now it's,
we've developed this very weird society.
We have insulated people from all of the
ugly realities of eating meat and of
wearing leather.
I mean,
we're sitting on leather chairs.
Didn't think about it once.
This used to be a fucking cow.
Yeah,
it's some a shot this cow and turns it
into a nice chair.
No one minds sitting on a cow that's
dead,
but no one wants to see that dead cow
laying on the ground.
The eyes open and blood hanging from his
ankles people,
and I think it's important for people to
see that.
I mean,
my kids have seen a lot of dead animals.
It's not sad.
It's a little sad,
but it's not like they don't think of it
as sad.
They think of it as just like a part of
life and that's what we eat.
Yeah.
Dad brings a deer home in a cooler.
Dad brings a pig home in the front of
the quad with his bow,
with a buddy earl.
It's totally normal.
They see me drag it off the quad and
shoot down with the hose and quarter it
and debone it and,
and they help me package it and grind
immedion's totally normal to them it
should be normal,
but there's a connection between the
death and what we're eating,
which a lot of people just don't have.
And I love that.
That to my kids already have that.
It's a good thing.
I think.
Well,
I,
I think that we have a real problem in
this society where so many people,
somewhere in the neighborhood of 95 to
97 percent of the people you meet and
the number of people that have actually
seen animal die.
It's like,
you know,
two or three like what is the,
what's the population of people that
hunt in North America?
Let's just guess,
guess the prop population of the US that
hunts.
I'm going to say it's
three percent that,
that might be high.
Even three out of 100.
What do you think it is?
It's probably less than three for sure.
Let's see what it is.
What population of the United States of
America hunts Jamie's raising his
eyebrows,
right?
It might be it set on technicality here,
but it says there's 100,
one point 6 million
Americans that have participated 16 and
older that uh,
yeah.
Fishing fish and wildlife shows that
100,
$100.
A lot of people behind you.
But that must have painted.
Yeah.
Participated in wildlife related
activities.
Oh Wow.
That's really,
that's,
that includes like pig fuck.
That includes wildlife watching.
Oh,
wildlife watch it.
And I typed in popular.
That's definitely a lot of difference.
That's a lot different.
Um,
does,
that's all they came up.
There's got to be a population of actual
number of hunters.
I mean this is back in.
That's the other thing too,
is like there's a hierarchy,
like people don't have a problem with
people fishing.
No,
no,
no problem.
Or posting a photo with their fishing
pole and catch.
Yeah.
Hey,
you got some food.
What's different between that present?
Maybe that's what's the difference
between now and a deer,
but here's,
there's a warm,
here's the will.
They're warm and they have for a movie
made about them.
Uh,
they talk.
What about Nemos fuck.
Nimo.
Nobody cares about finding nemo gets no
love.
He doesn't get any less.
I was thinking of this though,
like,
you know,
because I have kids and my kids eat
meat.
Right?
And I feel like imagine if you made a
law that after the age of 16 years old
in America,
if you want her to eat another
hamburger,
you had to kill two hours to two
animals.
Like,
like you can go to a place like whatever
it is,
like a of a ranch where they processed
me and there's a cow there and there's a
rifle there and you go,
okay,
if you want to be a meat eater from now
on,
from their 60th birthday on,
the only way to eat meat in the future
is if you got to do it yourself at least
twice.
Can't just do it once now.
Kill a cow,
watch,
get processed,
and then you got to,
you got to wait like a month or whatever
it is and go back and take another
animal's life.
And then you earn the right to eat meat
the rest of your life.
Imagine how many people wouldn't be able
to do that.
They're happy to eat meat,
but there's that disconnection with the
actual death part
problem with forcing people to do it.
Just like got to have a problem with
forcing people to think people should be
forced to get rid of their garbage.
It's just a wild concept that it is an
interesting concept,
but I think there's services like,
like taking your garbage and bring it to
the garbage dump.
I don't think you should have to go to
the garbage dump,
go to the landfill and drop your garbage
off.
I'm,
I'm happy that there's someone that gets
paid to pick up the bins and dumped the
garbage into the garbage truck and then
drive it to the bit that I'm happy that
that exists.
I liked that.
I liked the fact that someone takes care
of your sewage.
I agree.
I like the fact that I can buy a steak
for sure.
All I'm saying is like,
yeah,
if you could earn the right to eat
steak,
you know,
say you have to do it every time.
You wouldn't.
You wouldn't have to like kill a cow
every time you learn to eat more.
It's like once you finish that cal,
you need to kill another one.
I'm just saying everyone should know
what it's like to take an animal's life.
No,
I agree with you to eat meat.
I agree.
Everyone should probably know what it's
like because.
Because if you don't,
it's hard to respect that animal enough.
Like,
like I was saying,
like my,
my,
my kids don't.
We don't
waste deer meat.
Like if it's on their plate,
they eat it.
If they don't eat it,
I put it in there,
eat it next day or whatever it is.
You know,
there's,
there's always a lesson to be to be
taught when you're eating wild gained
that you,
that you've hunted yourself.
I think.
Well I think there's a problem whenever
there's a disconnect,
right?
It's like,
I think there's a problem with if money
just comes for free,
there's a problem with your meat.
Just comes from a store,
is it?
There's a weird disconnect between the
actual thing that's living and then
eating it and most people,
the vast majority of people are
completely disconnected from that.
Maybe that's all that's the case with
farming vegetables to most people.
I don't think they have an appreciation
for vegetable being a life form.
You're,
you're consuming that,
you know,
there's a growth process.
It's a living thing.
He pulled it out of the ground.
You Cook it,
you eat it.
I mean,
this disconnect I think is real too
because there's a real good feeling that
I get when I eat vegetables that have
grown in my garden,
you know?
I mean,
I love it.
I really,
I really enjoy it.
I get a kick out of it and there's a lot
of people who look down on us for
hunting who are say like,
you're a Vegan who just eats nothing but
vegetables and fruit,
whatever it is.
And uh,
you know,
they're looking at us like we're crazy
for,
you know,
the impact we have on the animals,
killing them,
whatever.
But like a lot of the vegetables that
people eat nowadays are grown in places
that used to be rainforest,
like the Amazon just getting whacked
down just to grow corn,
stuff like that.
You know what I mean?
Like there's a lot of it is just cattle,
right?
Isn't that Amazon a lot of the
deforestation.
I think that the primary,
a lot of ethanol to though isn't for,
for corn,
you know there's.
But I think hardwoods,
the chopped a lot of it down for
hardwoods and they dropped a lot of it
down to in order to provide grazing
lands for cattle.
They going the future.
All of the vegetables and stuff we're
going to be.
I was talking to Kelly about this a lot.
There's a lot of things that are
happening now with technology that I
think a lot of like the vegetables and
stuff that we're going to eating or
going to be grown vertically instead of
on these massive farms have like these
huge,
like 100,000
Acre ranch is full of vegetables.
It's all gonna be grown like in smaller
spaces,
you know,
super,
super efficient growing and smaller
spaces to feed more people with less
space.
I wonder if they could do be crazy.
It's gonna be crazy.
Yeah,
that would be crazy.
I mean there's probably some real
benefits to that,
but I wonder if they could do that with
grain.
We're going to have to do something with
our population keeping growing and more
people and more demand for food and less
space to grow it.
You know,
there's gonna be an inflection point
where somebody's going to have to do
something.
But I think technology is moving in that
place where.
And that's the thing.
I,
I fully get like the people who hate on
me on say,
social media,
whatever on my instagram,
if I post a photo of my,
if I did post a photo of me getting an
elk or whatever it was and all these
people get uppity.
But um,
because a lot of people can't go
hunting.
I don't live in a place where they can
go hunting and get their own meat.
They live in a city,
live in New York City or Shanghai or
Buenos Aires or whatever,
and they did so unrelatable to them,
you know?
No,
I understand that.
I appreciate that.
And you know,
I think that social media is very
strange in that regard too because
people are always looking for people or
things.
You get pissed off out.
Oh yeah.
They don't get mad if I post pictures of
cooking though.
No,
they don't.
I mean a few.
There's a few like proselytize very
games.
You're going to get cancer,
man.
There was one of the alleys do that.
I think cancer comes from meat.
He if all meet gabby cancer now fucking
stupid.
That is everyone would have cancer,
like literally 95 percent of the
population with cancer.
So there's a few epidemiological studies
that have fuck people's heads up because
they've Kerr corresponded.
They're related.
The idea of eating meat to poor health,
but these people that have eaten meat,
they don't just eat meat.
They've eaten meat along with sugar and
alcohol consumption.
Cigarettes and lifestyle.
They don't factor those things in there
like a,
like a 30 ounce prime rib.
Your body is impossible for your body to
process that.
Like more likely they're eating burgers
with sugary bonds and processed meat and
bullshit.
When I eat meat,
I normally meet the.
That's like the size of my palm or a
smaller,
you know,
eight wild game and it's that size.
I think it's easy for my body to process
that.
Eating like a prime rib that's hanging
off both sides of your plate,
like Fred Flintstone.
That's difficult I think for your body
to process that.
I just got it.
That's not scientific.
I just look at it and go,
there's no way I can.
My body's going to deal with that.
Where's it going to fit?
It's going to stay in it for 30 years.
You know?
They always say that it's going to stay
true to.
That's all nonsense to.
Wasn't Kelly's talking about like,
are they shooting his butt out and
stuff?
He was talking about talk.
Yeah,
he was talking about um,
when you go on these extreme fasts and
then all this weird stuff that comes out
of the inside of your gut comes out.
Yeah,
I would try that just to look at that
stuff,
see what this stuff looks like.
Yeah.
I would try it,
but I wouldn't want to.
I wouldn't want to look at it.
I definitely would want like the,
like the,
you know,
when like when you have a baby and they
put up like a curtain sometime to see
anything like that.
Like,
okay,
I'm going to put my legs up.
Someone's got a visual of that,
cut my legs up and somebody,
someone out there doing all that stuff.
You grow your own vegetables.
I don't know.
I travel half the time.
I'm gone from home like literally half
the time.
So it's really difficult to.
Is it hard getting good vegetables on
the Big Island?
Um,
no there's not,
it's,
it's actually really easy.
It was really good farmer's markets.
I'm lucky because my,
my mom and her boyfriend have a really
neat,
like a hydroponic killer vegetable
garden.
Oh Wow.
So like we'll trade,
a lot of times I'll,
I'll give them venison and I'll get
really good ideas from them and stuff
like that.
That's great trade.
That's cool.
Yeah.
So there's,
there's a lot of meals that we do where
like no one has touched that meal except
for my family was.
It's cool.
I love Zan has a,
she's got a macadamia farm
on the big island and she raves about it
up there.
Man,
she loves it.
I listened to part of her podcast if you
haven't finished it yet,
but she's amazing.
She's funny.
She's,
you know what man?
They fucked up.
They really did fuck up.
They fucked up when they blew it on.
That lady is not racist.
She's definitely mentally ill,
but she's open about it.
She's not racist and they,
they just,
they just jumped on the opportunity to
virtue signal and to cry out against
racism and to take a stand.
But they took a stand against a woman
that has mental problems,
who's on all sorts of medication?
Who they knew about it.
I mean,
she's been.
She was put in a mental hospital for
nine months when she was a kid and she's
hit by a car.
I mean she had a severe brain injury and
ever since then she's had multiple
personality disorder.
She's been on a host of different
medications and they knew about this.
Everybody knew about this.
They should have known that.
It's basically like taking a person
who's got a broken leg and getting mad
that they limp.
It's what they did.
Yeah.
I mean they have a person who had brain
problems who,
who tweets a bunch of wacky shit.
She's on Ambien and drinking and smoking
pot and even then she wasn't being
racist.
She wasn't.
She didn't know that lady was black.
The lady didn't even look black.
If you look at her,
you look at a picture of her.
She does not look black.
She just thought she was being funny and
she thought she was making a solid point
that she was going to expand upon what
you woke up in the morning as she
literally said,
that just all fucked up on Ambien and
pot and drinking.
I listened to as crazy.
Yeah.
That was fucked up.
That happen to her and it sucks that or
show got canceled.
Well the new one sucks.
The nuanced sucks.
It's going down the toilet.
So.
Hey,
I'm sorta the same subject.
Did you see the,
that Rad documentary about the white
woman who ran the Naacp and fricken act
like a black lady?
I know who she is,
but Rachel Dolezal best,
best frigging documentaries or as well
as incredible documentary.
Yeah,
insane.
She out of her mind,
they kept asking her if she was black
and she would just straight up like at
first she said yes.
And then she said like it's not that
important.
And then she was like tanning herself
and like putting all this brown on
herself and getting like weaves and
doing her nails,
like how she thought like black people
would do their nails.
Like it was super weird.
And then she ran.
She ran the NAACP.
It was just a wild documentaries.
That chick was just in outer space.
It's hilarious that she ran the NAACP.
Yeah,
probably did a good job and she had a
huge impact.
She was like amazing at her job.
Supposedly in the,
in the documentary is saying that she
got all this stuff done at that they
were trying to do for a long time and
she was really,
really good at doing her job.
It just sucked that she was actually a
white lady who was acting the whole
time.
Well,
what's really fucked oct
is Naacp stands for the National
Association for the advancement of
colored people.
You cannot call African-american's
That is a fucking slur.
They have slur in
their title.
We're leaving in weird times.
Men can say people of Color,
which is fucking bizarre.
Yeah.
You can't say colored people as well.
You can say people of color.
The same words just twisted around.
Dude.
I had a um,
it's messed up.
It's like you can just be like labeled a
racist or sexist or whatever for like
saying like,
Oh yeah,
yeah,
that's wild.
Um,
I had a 23 and me DNA tests done and
they're pretty good.
Yeah.
And I was hoping I was.
If I was more than 10 percent black,
I was going to start dropping bombs,
but a one point six.
So one point six,
one point six percent African,
pretty strong,
it's all Dick.
And uh,
when,
when they did that thing about Elizabeth
Warren,
I did find out what percentage.
She is a Elizabeth Warren who claim to
be native American and she did a test,
she's like one,
one,
100th of what I am like,
it's literally like her saying she's,
yeah,
her saying she's a native American is
literally like me saying I'm African
American but I have more of a claim,
have far more like more than I think
some,
some insane number,
like a factor of more African in me and
she has native American and I'm not even
remotely native American.
Remotely African.
Yeah.
I'm one point six percent of one point
six percent African in me and she has
like some fucking really stupid number.
What is the dump?
It's like point zero zero.
I don't even know how to make sense of
all that stuff she had.
That was what happened was a harvard
researcher looked into it and gave a
number that was very vague.
That would be like one and 500,
12 to one and 1020 fourth,
something like that.
That sucks.
It sucks.
It sucks that that's the thing,
like who gives a shit,
but she got into Harvard because of
this,
which she claimed she was native
American when she got in.
That was claiming that she was a minor.
Was Hartford,
right?
Correct.
I'm being honest with that.
Was it Cambridge?
Whatever.
The university.
Shenandoah university by claiming that
she was native American,
so she got a special scholarship because
of that.
Literally like me going to Morehouse and
saying,
I'm African American,
except I have a far better claim.
You have a much higher percentage.
Much higher.
That's so crazy.
Wild.
Meanwhile,
she's so nuts like because trump was
always calling her pocahontas and trump
said that if,
how,
how is it that you can't.
If you said the wrong thing on your
podcast,
people will be up in arms,
but it's unreasonably president can say
whatever the hell he wants to say.
He's making tending to be a native
American.
He was joking about heart.
She's not really native American,
and he called her pocahontas and he said
if she took a DNA test and showed that
she was native American,
he would donate a million dollars to a
charity of your choice.
So she,
after this fucking test that basically
showed she has these smallest measurable
possibility.
Native American in her was requiring him
to pay.
You should pay Harvard for the money
back built from them were at school.
Did she go to trying to find the actual
thing it seems.
I think she actually got a job at
Harvard.
Not.
Didn't go there for education.
Oh,
she got a job there because of trying to
find out.
Okay,
we'll figure it out.
But that's hilarious.
The I.
The idea that that is something you can
lean on is so goddamn crazy.
Listen,
you're a white lady.
I'm a white guy.
Shut the fuck up.
Okay.
You're not.
There's no.
There's not a part of you that has been
discriminated against because of the
fact that you're native American.
It just doesn't exist.
It's not true.
That's just so fascinating to me.
People love to be a victim.
They love to say,
you know,
it was my growing up was hard because
I'm one,
150,000
native American.
Crazy,
crazy.
And where does it stop?
Like is it,
is it,
is it like,
is it cool to say that if you're two
percent or 10 percent or 50 percent,
like where's it,
where's it?
That's what I'm saying.
At one point six percent,
I really don't feel like I could drop
right.
10,
it's not 10 percent.
Like I'm mostly Italian.
I'm like three quarters of Italian so I
can call someone a Guinea Guinea no
problem,
but two times don't give a fuck if you
call them guineas like okay,
like there's no really,
there's no good slurs for Italians work,
you know,
they have successfully integrated into
society.
But when my grandfather used to tell me
about,
he came over here when he was a boy from
Italy and he would tell me about how bad
it was about how much they were
discriminated against.
It was,
it was hard core.
I mean they were treated a lot of the
same way.
Racist People Treat Mexicans today.
An Irish,
same thing.
Same thing,
yeah.
Yeah,
and that's my background is Italian and
Irish.
Mostly.
Someone got fucked by a black person
somewhere,
somewhere.
One point six percent know how many
generations.
I guess the claim is that she used her
claim that she's native American to get
a job.
Yes.
Not.
Not to get into school,
get a job at Harvard,
at one at Harvard,
one at Pennsylvania.
So she did it twice.
Give that money back.
But I love the DNA test though.
I love the DNA test just proves it.
We're all like something.
We're all a bunch of shit.
Like,
you know what I mean?
I'm like 30 things of whatever.
You know what I mean?
Like it does.
Does it matter?
Not really.
Shouldn't matter.
Well really we're all African.
All of us.
Because that was the original human
being.
It depends who you ask.
I mean we came from our human beings
evolved from Africa.
If you believe in evolution,
if you believe in evolution is where it
gets a big f.
There were Sorta,
listen man,
if we stopped this podcast right now,
we could shoot technol for another half
hour.
Okay,
let's do it.
Let's do it ladies.
Gentlemen.
Shane Dorian falling.
Shane Dorian eight.
Oh,
eight on twitter and Shane Dorian is
that,
you know,
one thing.
So it might be failed.
I'm really just on instagram.
Shane Dorian,
fake Shane Dorian early.
No,
I'm not on twitter.
This son of a bitch.
You got me.
Whoever you are.
Don't follow that piece of shit.
Father,
real one.
Shane.
Dorian on instagram and your hbo
documentary.
Momentum generation.
When does it out?
It's on Hbo on December Eleventh.
Okay.
Well we,
we'll tweet it when it comes out again.
Sweet.
Thanks brother.
Thanks for having shoot some technical
haunts.
We'll see in a little bit with sober
October.
Recap.